[Laughter]
foreign
hey everybody it's Friday night and
we're still alive yeah
I was sitting here coughing and changing
like oh I'll wait till you get done
coughing I said man I will make that
coffin cinematic as [ __ ] so let that
[ __ ] roll
she was like it was like straight from
it was like Cinema
fine film
yeah yeah okay film you got to watch out
you guys because
Tom has been at the biker bar this
afternoon for several hours yeah so he's
already pre-gaming so he's probably
gonna be incoherent but not into this
all right
Amy gave me two double she gave me two
very [ __ ] stiff singles they're
doubles but she charged me for singles
Amy say you had two two yeah or really
kind of four no just two yeah
too Amy goes good goes damn you got a
little Slimmer [ __ ] looking good she
goes but your face looks all [ __ ] up I
said yeah that's awesome yeah man your
face looks awesome it's your face look
all [ __ ] up gee thanks and I said yeah
yeah
Her Sister Wives [ __ ] rough man
[ __ ]
she's like
she's a biker girl she's like your your
eyes look like they're all just black
man you look like a raccoon says I'm not
getting a whole lot of sleep you know
[ __ ] makes it kind of Insomniac I wake
up every couple hours
I do too on this [ __ ] man I gotta come
off this [ __ ] but you gotta do what you
gotta do it's like the Holy Grail man of
[ __ ] stacks and I'm just
it's good though I can feel it working
and I'm just hitting week two
my legs [ __ ] tearing me up if I were
to drop my drawers man my whole [ __ ]
legs nothing but one big bruise where
this thing just makes [ __ ] goose eggs
every time I inject it
which is like a common reaction with
this
it just beat you up and I'm not really
sleeping that well
you remember how soundly I used to sleep
well yeah but I'm not either but I don't
know if it's uh if it's that [ __ ] or if
it's just no because I used to be able
to like sleep through and sometimes I'd
get up like because I had to pee or
something like that but now I have to
get up like two or three times to pee
like in the middle of the night well and
the thing about it too is that obviously
Wednesday night because the hurricane
was hitting uh we didn't get much sleep
that night because it was so [ __ ]
loud and we were like afraid to get you
know that something was gonna happen and
then like the power went out and like
all this other kind of so it got hot in
there and [ __ ] like that so we didn't
really get but last night I actually got
decent sleep because I was exhausted
yeah I mean same as that same with me I
mean last night was the best sleep I've
had in two weeks on this [ __ ] yeah and I
only woke up once yeah I did too I woke
up one time because I had to pee but
that's good and the rest is and then I
got back in bed and fell right back to
sleep which never happens usually I lay
there for like an hour an hour and a
half but I I think it's because we were
so exhausted like from the night before
yeah because I the hurricane night I
think I maybe
three hours and it was broken because
like I said I tried to fall asleep and
then like I kept waking up because of
the noise and then I was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] this I'm gonna go put like earplugs
in so I put earplugs in and then I fell
asleep for an hour or two and then I
woke up and then the power was out and
then it was hot in there and I was just
like [ __ ] it and then like finally at
four o'clock I was like okay I can't
sleep anymore
because it was so noisy is there are
there any glasses over here I can read
this or I gotta go get no you got to go
why didn't you bring your glasses I
[ __ ] forgot okay y'all keep showing
up What's your deal man he's just so
disorganized where's my glass where's
this where's that did you forget your
head if it wasn't screwed on
but yeah so um I have to say like
considering
I looked real quick at like some of the
hurricane uh damage like from Florida
like where it first came on Shore and I
was like man we got so [ __ ] lucky we
didn't have
like I said we're about 30 miles 28 30
miles something like that like north of
downtown Orlando so we were in The Cone
but we were kind of like on the edge of
the cone and just the [ __ ] that we had
was bad enough you know what I mean like
with the wind and the rain and
everything like that I kind of feel like
I think the main problem through here
was in in Orlando was flooding yeah you
know I'm gonna show you all what this
shit's doing to me I gotta wait are you
gonna take your pants off what are you
doing I'm gonna show them right here
Jesus Christ it ain't gonna hurt enough
are you sure you have underwear look at
you
why why would you do that to yourself
[Laughter]
it's worth it
worth it's worth it well then quit
complaining about it then it's just
[ __ ] painful man
[ __ ]
she loves it when I take my clothes off
don't listen
Zach said uh as much as I love my BF we
can't share a bed when sleeping uh he
sleeps cold I'm hot we both like to
spread out and move around and he snores
yeah actually we've been trying to kind
of I sleep in the man cave sometimes and
I'll come back in late and yeah but it
drives her crazy because uh
I get grabby you know what I'm talking
about I'm gonna try to get something
well it's not just that she's sleeping
and she's like and I says no I'm gonna
get something I'm like please don't like
wake me up in the middle of the night
for Christ's sake it's like it's bad
enough that I can't get any sleep as it
is and it's like I always wake up really
early roundness how am I going to sleep
around this right well plus you snore
and you're you're plus you snore all
right and you've kind of thrashed around
and like talk in your sleep and you
always are like listening to headphones
and I can always hear
coming from the headphones people
the boobs are amazing and she's [ __ ]
getting back in shape she's sucking
looking real good she's good her waist
is getting small again [ __ ] the legs
are looking fantastic because she's been
on that damn bicycle doing third like 30
miles a day
hmm you've been off protocol for a
couple days that's okay you you need a
little bit of rest and then you're gonna
go you know you're still not done but
and then the protocol she's on is
[ __ ] she's getting real good response
we're gonna do a photo shoot here soon
I'm gonna photo shoot that [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] share I'm gonna share with
you all [ __ ] you'll see what
I'm talking notice that he didn't ask me
if that was all right it's already a
done deal it's already a done deal I've
already shared I've already shared I got
good I got good I got good photos of
Jenny that I've seen that on Instagram
and [ __ ] like that it's just gonna be
like it's not gonna be x-rated or
anything the [ __ ] Jenny likes [ __ ]
photo shoot she's just about time for a
photo shoot
thank you thank you glad to see y'all
are doing okay yeah we're we're glad too
like the worst that happened
um we didn't have any damage actually
the street looks pretty good like I
looked around out there it didn't look
like we just were like branches down and
[ __ ] like that uh the power went out
um it was out for what like
I think it went out between one and two
a.m no it went out at about three oh did
it I don't know well I didn't know what
time I was awake when it went out
yeah and then it came back on like
between five and six I think it was more
like five and six the next afternoon I
guess it was and then we discovered that
we didn't have running water either like
we didn't know this earlier because
there was still water in the system yeah
and you know we just said oh the water
pressure is low but then but then we're
like oh wait no we don't have any water
um so we called them but they were
already working on it so yeah by the
time the water ran out it was only like
another hour before we had water yeah I
think about eight o'clock at night they
finally fixed it and like got the water
going because we were just kind of like
oh [ __ ] we actually don't have any water
that's not good it was all good but yeah
like other than that that was the worst
of it and honestly off is it what pissed
me off
was that the power goes out
so I waited [ __ ] couple hours and I
said well I guess I'll have to put the
[ __ ] generator together
the first generator my older generator I
said this should be enough to just run
the downstairs like the [ __ ]
freezer in the refrigerator and some
appliances so we can cook on
so I'll run that but then I had a
problem with that one so then I said
[ __ ] it so I busted it out the brand new
one and it started it for the first time
and that's like a [ __ ] real nice one
that's oh yeah so it was kicking ass the
new one the blue one blue one I forgot
what I forgot what company it was
and I only ran it for like four hours
and then the [ __ ] power came back on
so all that [ __ ] was for nothing
I should have just waited it out
I mean and the thing about it was that
one night thing was that one silver
lining of the hurricane was that the
temperature plunged down to like 65
degrees
so we didn't even need the air
conditioning we just opened the windows
and it was like a beautiful Cool Breeze
that came in and I was like [ __ ] it was
I was sitting there by the window in my
office because I opened it me and Pookie
sat there like all day just reading and
I got cold yeah I put a jacket on put a
sweater on put my sweater on that's
where I'm outside that's what made that
hurricane good for us is that it wasn't
hot it was cold cool and um by the time
I was watching it live on my tablet when
I still had power I watched it started
watching it hit
Altamonte Springs right [ __ ] south of
us
and uh by the time it hit there it was
down to Tropical force winds so it
wasn't a hurricane it was about 75
that's when it hit us which is right on
the I think 74 is the cutoff for
tropical storm and then 75 is Hurricane
so it was a category one
when it hit us yeah one slash and like I
said that was um that was where the eye
was which was about 25 30 miles south of
us so we were still in the cone but like
I said
even that like even being outside of it
and even weakening I'm glad it wasn't
any worse than that because that was
like bad enough it was just like it was
like making the whole house Rattle and
Creek and [ __ ] like that and I was kind
of like worried about it
because it was like so so loud
so loud and I can't even imagine like I
said I was watching earlier like the
[ __ ] from Lee County like right around
Naples and [ __ ] like that man that place
looks like a [ __ ] new kid yeah
there's like there's especially like
right on the coast it's like there's
some buildings left still there but
they're all [ __ ] up and then like
there's gaps in between where there used
to be houses and now there's nothing
like the the sea just came in and just
swept it all away there's nothing left
pookie was tripping too she was up here
right near the the top of the stairs
which is centralized on the [ __ ] top
floor and from there she can see all the
windows and she was looking at pretty
much trying to look at all the windows
keep an eye on everything like what the
[ __ ] is going on and I pop out [ __ ]
what's up hook and she's like wind's
blowing I said yeah it's blowing she
didn't like it yeah well like I said she
was like well she was wigging out she
didn't seem to care that much about the
power going out because like I said it's
a cat she can see in the dark she
basically just sat like at the head of
the stairs like she always sits like her
little guard position making sure
Beijing doesn't come up here you know
Garden you guys and she just stayed
there but the next day when we opened
all the windows and especially like I
was here in the office and I had the
windows open and you know the curtains
were blowing and she was super nervous
like she would she came and like sat
right by me and I was reading and then
like the curtains would blow and she'd
be like
and she was like and I kept going it's
okay book is just a curtain it's just a
curtain but she kept like freaking out
about it and finally I had to take it
and like tie it behind the thing because
she was just like losing her mind that
she'd like run and like hide under the
couch and like peer out it's just it was
so so sad and so I kept like trying
because she really
I mean I think she came to see you a
couple times you were kind of [ __ ]
around with the generator and everything
but most of the day she sat like right
by my leg and she was just like looking
around really nervous because she knew
like [ __ ] was weird because we don't
usually have the windows open we don't
usually have the curtains open you know
so she would and she could hear she
could hear the generator yeah like
making noise and so she was like she was
like really really nervous so she just
like kept like she kept walking circles
around me and like looking at me and
being like what's wrong like what's
going on I don't understand and I kept
trying to you know
yeah Willow Lee asked how Pokey was yeah
that's what we were saying she's beige
game two shits she didn't get it she's
been through a bunch of them she's like
yeah these are fun I think when it first
came she was like sitting on the porch
or sitting outside watching me yeah she
doesn't care she's like yeah yeah you're
gonna get it she's cheering it on she's
kind of an old lady yeah she's not old
old but she's older yeah she's an older
cat so yeah she's been through a few so
she's like she doesn't give a crap and
she's been through three or four of them
yeah probably because she's what is she
13 14. something like that
um Zach says by the way Jen did you show
Tom my boyfriend with the fake titties
on yet no I haven't yeah Zach sent me a
picture of that I forgot I should write
a show yeah oh the other fake titties
nude yeah damn
damn didn't even see him I know he did
yeah well the picture will still be [ __ ]
those dudes the fake titties man [ __ ]
Zach man knock it off dude
y'all y'all are men y'all are man be man
you let people do what they want Tom
nobody's nobody wants to do what you
want to do
or what you want to tell them to do I'm
just I'm just you're trying to tell
everybody else what to do that's my job
it's not though it is now who gave you
that job myself
that figures God
God no such thing God did it no such
thing
telling you Zach says uh you sweet
innocent summer child here in Indiana 67
feels hot when we get out of our Winters
and guamacun said the phrase plunge down
to 67 tells you all you got to know
about Florida heat that's what I'm
saying the fact that iPhone 3 feels
pretty cool
the fact that I could be sitting by the
window and it was 67 outside with the
breeze and I had to have a jacket that
just goes to show like how [ __ ]
miserable and hot it is here usually
that 67 actually felt cold to me it felt
really good I went for a ride today man
it felt beautiful it was beautiful
outside wind was blowing through and
blowing through the [ __ ] jackets and
[ __ ] knows it was good real good it was
it was warm today but it wasn't like it
had kind of a cooler Breeze because I
went out I had to go down to Publix and
get some stuff and so I kind of went out
but
not it's still it was still kind of warm
but not bad
yeah well at least it when I was
watching news it was wild yeah I mean
I'm just really really glad that it had
broken up and kind of weakened by the
time it got here I went and now I'm kind
of like wondering how the shit's gonna
go because like I said my sister is
supposed to come to Orlando
tomorrow and me and her are supposed to
go to Disney on Sunday
and so I don't know
how it's going I think that the Orlando
Airport had some damage but I don't know
if they've reopened yet like some of the
other airports like open but I don't
know if Orlando did yet it wasn't open
yesterday so I don't know how she's
gonna get down here or what the [ __ ] is
going to go on but we'll see and I think
Disney closed too
yesterday or the day before yesterday
because I imagine like nobody had power
because everybody's power was out
Zach says pretty soon I'm going to
rearrange my room so I have a view out
the window when I wake up and the leaves
change color man
I kind of wish that I could see the
leaves change color leaves don't change
color here yeah they do they're either
kind of green or they're they well they
change color when the tree dies yeah
winner when are they when are they going
to go into a into a kind of but it's not
really the same no it's not like it is
up north no it's not really the same
where you get like all this beautiful up
north red and orange Four Seasons really
over here you kind of only have two
two or three one and a half I would say
one and a half the summer has the summer
is also kind of a monsoon season in
Florida it rains every day a certain
certain months kinda yeah most of the
summer yeah and you know that's what I
mean it's just kind of like
with the hurricane it was by the time it
got here it was really really bad but
it's we've had storms almost that bad
that aren't hurricanes California has
won one season that's it air
conditioning
it's a desert yeah it's a cool desert
basically
the update posts you guys made yeah
because I posted on YouTube uh reminded
me of a Donner Party letter
nowhere near his Grimmer hopeless though
yeah I didn't like say that we had to
like resort to like eating each other or
anything like that it was like serious
so many supplies and [ __ ] we had good
that's what I mean it was literally like
nothing it you know literally nothing
like the power was out for less than 24
hours running water was off for less
than 24 hours
we had food we had generators
we were fine it wasn't hot out we did we
were fine it was fine like everything
was back on and last night we were just
like [ __ ]
watching we were watching movies again
or not actually we didn't want you know
what we watched if any of you guys have
shutter I think I brought this up before
but they have that series that's um 101
you know scary scenes in horror or
whatever and they're putting one up like
every week I don't know what day they
put it up though Thursday or Friday but
there was a new one up last night so I
watched that and then we've been
watching
because remember that show that was on
History Channel that was it was called
the food that built America right
and then there was another one that was
called what was that we watched after
that it was the food that built America
and then it was the something else that
built America
and I can't remember what it was and now
we're watching the Machines That Built
America so the ones they did last night
was like about power tools and then they
were saying that they have two seasons
in California hot bread no
Southern California and I lived there
for a long time until 81.
it was one season
around Long Beach
Long Beach and um
San Diego
and it was like cool 70 degrees it
seemed like it was 70 degrees all year
round I don't even remember it ever
getting hot
dry too
so no humidity
only difference was every now and then
it would rain every now and then that
was about it that's all I remember
unless I'm not remembering it right you
might not be but I just don't remember
anything like nothing I mean considering
uh Hugo lives there now and yeah but he
might be up north that's true
California's big well yeah I know that
yeah I think southern California was
[ __ ] like air conditioning
thank you
first time I went to Mississippi and I
was a kid was the first time that to go
see my dad was the first time I ever
encountered hot weather it was just
mind-blowing I couldn't understand it
yeah
I didn't know that there was weather
and so I went to Mississippi
there's weather all night I just thought
it was air conditioning and rain that
that was it inside now there was no air
conditioning in any of that any of the
houses or buildings that I could
remember
but you didn't notice it it was
comfortable everywhere like 70 degrees
all the time that's what it seemed like
until you come to the South and discover
that we also have a season that kind of
feels like a Big Fat Sweaty greasy man
sitting on your head all year all year
round yeah so it's a natural defense
it's a natural defenses just to keep
other people out
and then I was a kid and the first thing
of it was just [ __ ] sweltering heat
first time I went to Mississippi it was
probably
I don't know this is sometime in the 70s
I was probably about seven or seven or
eight
and it was just [ __ ] mind-blowingly
hot
and I remember being out my first memory
of it I was out in front of I think my
grandmother's
yard
and I looked down at my feet and there
was one of those giant black locusts
with the [ __ ]
yellow stripes on it remember those
things yeah and it just my hair [ __ ]
stood up I'd never seen anything like
that I was like whoa what the [ __ ]
it was a trip like is it supposed to
look like that yeah huge
they're they're huge giants
and you don't see him anymore I used to
see him a lot but
the South's not really the same as it
was back when I was a kid
used to be
when I was a kid
if you saw a parking lot at night like
say from a mall
every one of those parking lights out in
the parking lot was nothing but just a
huge swarm of [ __ ] bugs I mean big
bugs and that's all gone now
I guess the the amount of bugs has
declined everybody had those damn
ultraviolet bug zappers on the back
porch remember those yeah and all night
long be killing the bugs would be a big
pile of bugs underneath there and
[ __ ]
toads at the bottom a bunch of toads
trying to eat all those bugs all those
in there with their mouth open yeah
trying to eat them
that's [ __ ] funny that's like the all
you can eat buffet yeah
and what was funny is that they had
those bug zappers
but they didn't make any difference so
they attracted the bugs so you could
kill them
why didn't they just
why'd they just turn it off and not
attract the bugs because the bugs were
going to be in clouds around your
[ __ ] house anyway so you might as
well winnow them all into one area and
then like kill them all off I guess so
you know what I mean but I remember it
seemed like there was an endless supply
when I was a kid
well I mean functionally they are there
is but you know
at least you kind of want and maybe
you're kind of hoping that it's like
maybe this will be a deterrent to others
so they won't come out there they'll go
somewhere else a lot of them were
cicadas
[ __ ] huge cicadas they get up and
down bug zapper they explode
they'd fall down all [ __ ] up some toad
try to eat it
hilarious
grandma says anyone remember the
mid-2000s Bravo's scariest movie moments
yeah I remember that fondly actually
I've watched it like several times
um he said that was my introduction to
so much stuff like a modern dance
Macabre in a way yeah I mean [ __ ] I talk
about that Stephen King book dance
Macabre a lot because I read that when I
was a kid I think it came out in 81 or
something like that and I read a lot
when I was a kid and I had a mission to
like watch or read like everything that
he talked about in there and it's like I
didn't succeed completely but I did see
like a good chunk of the stuff that was
in there and read it and stuff but yeah
I do kind of feel like I like to keep up
with those kind of lists because there's
always even though I feel like sometimes
I've seen like a large chunk of all the
good [ __ ] but there's always stuff that
slips through the cracks you know so you
always got to kind of like keep up with
it because I'm always kind of like
finding stuff that somehow
just slipped under the radar you know
he's saying that he's in L.A and it's
hot every day you don't know heat dude
L.A L.A I don't even think gets a
hundred
I don't and it's and humidity is always
low it can get to be 100 plus here with
100 humidity it's just it's
mind-bogglingly hot
but I don't remember real you know I
didn't live in L.A I lived I lived a
little bit just south of there
closest to La I've ever lived with
[ __ ] Long Beach
it's not that far
I don't ever remember getting hot
not really
maybe it might get 80 but it was dry
real dry
well and sometimes too I think that
if you're kind of just out being a kid
and like running around and stuff you
don't really think about it like it
doesn't bother you as much maybe
so there might be that too I don't
really know maybe I don't remember
anybody ever complaining about heat yeah
it's like I said it's dry whereas down
here everybody oh yes it's part of the
culture to go God damn it's hot
well it is yeah part of the problem part
of the problem though is that
Southerners are no longer acclimated to
the heat in the pre-air conditioner days
they didn't know any better they just
sucked it up they didn't know how hot it
was
their bodies that adjusted to it but now
you're in air conditioning all the time
then you step outside and it's like God
damn it's hot you want to go back inside
the air conditioning yeah like [ __ ] this
[Laughter]
which like I said I wouldn't go back I
don't I wouldn't go back to like time
for air conditioning not living down
here so if there was no air conditioning
I don't think most people would live
down here yeah no why would you why
would you want to spend your entire life
being that miserable and like
uncomfortable well they didn't know any
better than ones that did live here well
yeah like before AC that's like that you
didn't really have a choice you were
just kind of like you lived down here
and you just had to like deal with it
but now you do kind of have a choice
mostly so oh you know I've seen all the
old houses in Mississippi just out in
the middle of nowhere and they were kind
of like a Victorian style Plantation
kind of French Colonial looking house
with awnings that went around them and
like a porches that went around the
second floor and uh they all had like
glass doors that went from the seat
pretty much halfway up to the ceiling
all the way down the floor and you'd
open them up I don't remember what kind
of so you could walk outside and they'd
open up all the damn windows I guess
they had screens too
and because the way they were arranged
they they got circuit air circulation
and they had
you know in the 1800s they had canopy
beds with mosquito netting
there's like living in Vietnam you know
I don't think they knew any better they
just walked around in there you know
they had nice houses they just opened
all the doors and windows it wasn't
until the late 1800s they had electric
fans installed in them
but there's no way to air condition them
I've seen them try to do duct work metal
duct work and insulated it you can do it
but
it's a waste of money because the
insulation just isn't there
the
the distance in between the walls isn't
very much and you can't get a lot of
insulation in there and there's too much
glass
and to replace it with modern two pain
you know double pane glass to try to get
some insulation just [ __ ] cost you
millions and millions of dollars they
were just never meant for air
conditioning those houses
but they did live in them
they were pretty yeah they just walked
around with constant swamp ass
swarms and bugs and mosquitoes because
they had all the damn windows and doors
open candles and [ __ ]
and uh they got inside the damn canopy
bed to keep the mosquitoes out
they've been there cracking like crazy
man [ __ ] inside that damn thing
stinking and [ __ ] yuck
sweat
man I don't you know what I don't even
like getting out of the shower in the
air conditioning and getting kind of
like and having like wet hair and like
then like making the back of my neck
damp even that makes me uncomfortable
and I'm in the air conditioning there
was no bathrooms in the house it was an
outhouse
because and you had chamber pots yeah so
you didn't want you didn't want that in
the house
and a lot of times there weren't
kitchens in the houses that the the
kitchen was kind of like a remote thing
yeah and I mean usually it was just kind
of like
cooking outside it just had a roof you
know it was like a cooking station
at least in the South because you don't
need you don't need walls
if you're just gonna cook
you just need a roof
but you couldn't cook in the house you
just [ __ ] heat it up
so
food preparation was outside so it was
bathroom and you brought it in
or you ate it outside Southerners ate
outside when I was a little kid I was
just looking it's like might as well
we're already eating bugs anyway
because they're everywhere Fried Chicken
and watermelon and [ __ ] perch and
bluegill and brim and deep fry and
everything and okra fried okra making
the [ __ ] outside it's like a picnic
yeah
somebody said uh
Adriana said I hope you guys are all
right after the hurricane yeah we came
through just fine power was out and
water was out for a little less than a
day but we got it back last night and no
damage no nothing we didn't have any
flooding on our street or anything a lot
of streets did Flood but ours did not
um somebody
Camp guy said they make an air gun
called a Bug Assault
and you put table salt oh yeah and pump
it up yeah and shoots the salt like a
shotgun blast fun with flies it's more
of a novelty item yeah big assault I
remember that it's been around for a
long time I don't think I've ever seen
one like I've heard of it but I don't
think I've ever seen one pump shotgun
yeah
for shooting flies I can't imagine I can
imagine some dude at like some yeah
sweaty like wife beater like yeah with a
grizzled old white beard just sitting
there going you're fired yeah that's
some other Southern [ __ ] though killing
bugs that's something that's it I
remember when I was a little kid you'd
see these old dudes want to show up to a
diner with a [ __ ] fly swatters yeah
that's what I remember that [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] got a fly squatter in his
back pocket in a diner [ __ ] swatting
flies and throwing them on the [ __ ]
floor and [ __ ] like that so gross ass
[ __ ] so gross [ __ ] gross
killing the [ __ ] flies and [ __ ] on
the table he's eating on yeah
it's like that was some old they were
they were older than Boomers they were
like my grandparents age yeah I remember
those people well my yeah my grandma's
walking around with a damn flash my
grandparents had a fly swatter in the
house
now I remember mostly mostly the kids
got spanked with it if they were bad but
I don't remember the [ __ ] cracker ass
[ __ ] walking around with the
damn fly swatter in public yeah I've
seen that a few going into the truck
stop
yeah to eat and swatting flies when he
sees them yeah just like what the [ __ ]
this old dude walking around with damn
flashlight now what are they gonna live
that long
Willow says uh so where is Pookie where
is pokey is she back is she Behind the
Chair she was here a minute ago she was
here a minute ago yeah like I said she
has like she has her little pile of toys
over there and she so sometimes she sits
behind my chair and she throws her
little mouseie around like while we're
doing the show she a rages the
seems like she arranges the toys in a
little
area right here and then she'll lean up
against him like it's a wall of toys
she's funny
she's keeping an eye on a ball making
sure they're not going here she's like I
can monitor you [ __ ]
she'll probably like wander in here at
some point because she usually if she
knows we're in here doing the show
she'll usually come in and be like pay
attention to me why are you guys talking
to the screen again you know she's gonna
jump up on the sink and like there she
is there she is come here Folk
hey
Daddy pick you up what she's like what
she looked up here like why is everybody
looking at me
I'm old enough to when I was a kid I saw
real crackers I'm talking about [ __ ]
like Colonel Sanders style crackers they
didn't dress exactly like that they were
old when I see them but they were in the
[ __ ] rayon suits and [ __ ]
and those cheesy ass [ __ ] ties
dressed up like they were gonna go to
the church or something say hey boy hey
boy what your name is you know they're
like that and I'm just in [ __ ] it was
a trip man you're like what's up what's
your name
yeah who you working for no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no you gotta go
back on the other side of the tracks yo
yo y'all kind don't belong over here
it's like that you know
ah we don't cut y'all's here yeah for
really [ __ ] I remember I was old enough
to remember
yeah I remember people they were
[ __ ] they were [ __ ] they were
they were like all over my dad my dad
thought they were [ __ ] he couldn't
stand them he didn't like him yeah that
was like a great great yeah yeah
uh Adriana said are the houses in
FLorida tall Coastal houses in my
country uh are there like that the
what's a tall Coastal house like uh you
know because I guess like um there are
some here that are like that but I don't
know I kind of feel like a lot of the
houses in FLorida the newer ones are
just kind of all like those sort of like
Mediterranean
mcmansion type things
back in the old days they used to do
um these kind of like squat
Bungalow style houses like back in the
50s and 60s they used there's still a
lot of those around but you know they're
old they don't really build them like
that anymore most of the ones that we
have like our house is two-story but I
don't know I kind of feel like mostly
they do one story you can go on YouTube
you can go on [ __ ] Google Earth and
see see all of Florida
it goes across the [ __ ] it's Acro it
runs the whole Gambit
old Florida stuff is like 50s and 60s
looking houses there
short one-story cinderblock houses that
today are not real air well air
conditioned they are air-conditioned but
they're not real well air conditioned
kind of damp kind of musty smelling
houses with kind of flattish kind of
roofs on them they're just from another
era a lot of people we know live in
those yeah my grandmother had her house
was like that it was built in 1958 and
it had a flat it had a flat like tar
paper roof like it didn't have shingles
the roof was flat it was just like tar
paper and then like a layer of tar on
top of it back in the 50s and 60s
Trend cough uh back in the 50s and 60s
those were nice houses for Florida yeah
now that's passe you can there's they
you can get those cheap you can get yeah
there's lots of them still around like
people still live in them and you can
like and I've seen some that have been
like you know that they've uh done or
something like restored and that look
pretty nice but they just have a hard
time competing to what's on the market
after all all the prices of the
restoration usually when a person
restores a house like that they're doing
it because of the location uh because
it's it's in a decent location that they
want to be in that area for some reason
or another and it's like one of the
nicer ones and uh they want a house like
that because there's some people that
want those well yeah some people are
into like that mid-century kind of retro
yeah and they have the money to kind of
restore it and make it look like that
which is you know that's that's cool the
problem with them is that they tend when
you see them they tend to they tend to
look moldy because it's they've been
there for a long time they're usually
not in neighborhood hoods that have HOA
so people will spend a long time they'll
go a long time without a Fresh coat of
paint and we're in a tropical
environment so mold starts growing on
the outside of them because they sweat
because they're they're nice and cool in
the inside it's it's it's hurricane
proof it
it's they're kind of solar proof they
stay cool in the inside of them so they
kind of sweat on the outside and mold
grows on them yeah
um plus you get termites also if there's
any wood in there yeah if there's any
wood in there because we had that happen
in our house in Daytona which was built
in the 60s 63 64 something like that and
it was mostly concrete block but it had
like wooden framing like around some of
the doors and stuff like that and like
The Termites Ate like one of that so I
had to come in this house that we're in
is a two-story house
I guess
I guess it's four bedrooms
yeah I think technically technically I
think technically it's five bedrooms is
it technically five okay because this is
a bedroom that's a bedroom that's a
bedroom and then there's a bedroom
downstairs it's it's two stories
uh we have HOA here but it's not an
enclosed Community it may be one day
it's set up to where they could put
guard Gates on but yeah there's not a
garden they're not there yet if it gets
if the area gets more populated over
time that might probably happen they
tend to do that because they're still
building in this world right
um
we got I got this one for 4.75.
in California this would probably be a
two or three million dollar house at
least
um and Florida's not worth that much
uh you can get a really good deal
Florida at least I don't know maybe
right now you may not a lot of people
are moving here but at the time that I
got this
you could get and this was not one of
the choice houses really
it was just a good deal on a big one
knew it was newer this house is about
what 10 years 10 15 years old I think
it's 10 years old 10 or 11 years old
which is a little bit newer than the
house that we lived in before and it's
not perfect you know what I mean it's
it's the layout's a little crazy which
is one of the reasons why the price
wasn't that bad and the Brokers were
able to get to to get me the money to
get it because this this house at the
time that I bought it was had been on
the market or
would have been on the market for a long
time because because the landlord owns
another one just a couple houses down
and it's been vacant for more than two
years yeah he's just been he had been
renting this one out
but yeah I mean the thing yeah like you
said the the layout is a little weird
but I mean it's not bad it's just weird
proportions are strange in the rooms
but it's okay it's just yeah but it is
it is very large there's a lot of room
yeah these houses were kind of
they're kind of like MC Mansions they
were thrown together out of a catalog
the person whoever was gonna whatever
company was gonna
build a couple houses in one of these
developments would go yeah give me give
me a Model A do this and that uh over
here I want a model C uh get rid of this
and that and so the real estate
developers are just picking [ __ ] out of
a catalog to have the house built
the people that picked it out of the
catalog never intended to live in it
themselves so they're just you know they
don't care they just kind of throw it
together
um
you run into little things like the
fixtures like trains and uh like like
the drains and the sinks and the faucets
may not be super high quality you might
have to replace those you know they
start wearing out after seven eight
years you know well I kind of feel like
that's true and pretty kind of like
developed neighborhood like this where
they always just kind of unless you pay
for the upgrades they're gonna put like
the bottom of the barrel the cheapest
so fixtures and stuff it's time for a
lot of this [ __ ] to be replaced so
because it breaks
you replace it with something nicer than
it was in there before depending on if
you have the money at the time but
usually it's not really that much it's
like the difference between twenty
dollars and forty dollars
you know for the extra 20 you get
[ __ ] some fancy [ __ ] you know yeah
Charlie Huck says hi from Argentina I
really love the show well hey thank you
very much
um Tammy said like the Golden Girl house
yeah like the house on the Golden Girls
like because yeah that was set in
Florida so that's kind of what a lot of
the older uh that's one of the older
yeah that's the older ones look like
um Zach says the neighborhood I grew up
in was so weird one developer came in
building mcmansions they ran out of
money yeah another came in making
smaller houses then they ran out then a
third developer came in and finished
with little ranch houses yeah so it's
like they're just getting smaller and
smaller like I think is it Mansions are
losing games you don't want to imagine
yeah we were talking about about that
before where it's like it's a cool idea
I like the idea of having like something
that looks like Dracula's castle like
that would be Super Rad but I don't know
I kind of feel like in practice it would
just be like a giant pain in the ass
yeah you can go online and look at those
Urban exploration videos of abandoned
newer mansions and [ __ ] that was built
you know like you'll see a mansion it's
only eight years old and nobody's been
in there for four years and so they only
lived in it for four years they sit
there for another four years vacant and
you're like well how the hell could that
be vacant you'll see in the comment
sections contractors that build that
kind of [ __ ] sometimes it's the actual
contractor that built it oh yeah I
worked in that one you know I did this
and that
um
usually with the mansions
it's guys that have a bunch of money
of course
uh some of it's new money they've just
kind of stumbled into some money maybe
it's kind of ill-gotten gates
and they think to themselves I'll buy
this big ass mansion and I'll be popular
everybody will love it
so they buy this big ass Mansion they
pick it all out they build this mansion
they don't buy them they build them if
you have enough money for a mansion you
have enough money to build a mansion to
spec
so they pick it all out of a catalog
yeah I want a casino up here I want a
bowling alley down the bottom next to
the pool I want a bar there I want the
[ __ ] bowling machine I want slides
that go from the top stars to the bottom
you know what I mean when over watching
the pool and all this [ __ ] that seems
like really cool you know when you see
it you're like yeah that'd be [ __ ]
cool then
and when the thing's done and they even
buy all the furniture out of the catalog
when the thing's done it looks kind of
like a like a soulless Hotel
and it doesn't look like anybody lives
in it
so then you find out that he's in there
and who's he going to invite to come
over to this hotel his trashy ass
friends his trashy ass friends come over
and [ __ ] up his Mansion he goes I'm not
gonna have any of my trashy friends over
anymore I'm gonna have for my [ __ ] my
rich friends my classy ass foreign
because they got Mansions of Their Own
so he [ __ ] throws a party come on
over to my Mansion you know and then
nobody shows up because they got matches
of their own they don't give a [ __ ]
about your Mansion they're sick of
mansions all right
so then that dude's got in that mansion
and he ends up living in a tiny
apartment inside that mansion
because it's not really normal for you
to [ __ ] be comfortable in these big
Open Spaces
so when he's not in that running a
mansion and keeping it open
it's kind of like running a business
you need a butler to [ __ ] do shipping
and processing and in in
shipping and out shipping and running a
staff and making sure that [ __ ] all
the floors are being buffed and [ __ ]
the carpet cleaning machine you need a
big ass carpet cleaning machine to clean
all the carpets
to keep it's like running a business
so you're spending a lot of money to run
this you get sick of that so what they
do is they end up shutting the Mansion
down and living in a little tiny
apartment
and then they have all this money and
when they have to have fun they're not
having fun in the Mansion they're having
fun jumping on Jets and going to [ __ ]
clubs and hotels all over the world like
in Barbados and [ __ ] like that
so the mansion's useless actually
to the rich person
and then he finds out having a mansion
isn't all that big of a deal because he
starts meeting people that have seven or
eight of those things
and they're kind of like they use them
as private hotels
they're partying
and this Jet Set [ __ ] scene and then
when they want to go run off with the
girlfriend they go to one of one of the
Mansions they're there for a couple
weeks and then they leave
so and then and then when the when the
money runs out or they get sick of the
mansion
they demolish the Mansion or they just
abandon it sometimes and put the
property up for sale
they never resell the mansion
the Mansion is not worth anything only
the property's worth something
because a rich person that can afford
that [ __ ] property that has a mansion
on it has enough money to build their
own Mansion to their own specs on it so
he buys the property and has the old
mansion torn down and he builds a brand
new one on top of it
so Mansions are not an investment
they're a consumable
not not a new mansion
and not even an old one there's a lot of
Victorian style looking Mansions from
the 1800s made out of brick they look
beautiful but they don't live in them
you they're they're almost you almost
you can't live in them they're not
really good for central heating and air
and they're not modern and they're not
convenient to live in they might look
good from on the outside but you go on
the inside looks very dated
and they just
they're not as valuable as people think
they are
Adriana said do you guys have a pool we
do not
um and actually our old house we didn't
have a pool at the old house either the
community had a pool yeah uh this
community doesn't have a pool I don't
think does it uh I don't know I don't
think it has like a little tennis it has
a lake and a little park but yeah it has
a lake that you can like go on the boat
and you can swim in there if you want I
wouldn't but um you know fish in there
you can fish in there and [ __ ] like that
yeah row boats and [ __ ] yeah and do
boats but yeah I don't think there's a
pool uh in this one but yeah I mean we
have room back there if we wanted one
but I haven't put it yeah it would
probably be too much stronger costs a
lot of money and then you got then you
have to upkeep the pool and that's what
I mean I like them but I don't really
like all the work involved yeah
everybody I know that owns one gets sick
of them after a couple years they're a
[ __ ] a lot of money to keep running
properly it's one of those things
because like I said we were talking
about that the other day where I kind of
feel like if you come into like a lot of
money
and you're just kind of like oh I want
this that and the other thing and like a
lot of it seems like a cool idea yeah
and then like you might use it like a
few times but then after that like I
just feel like it's more trouble than
it's worth yeah you know what I mean
spending 600 a month [ __ ] keeping the
pool up or supposed to do [ __ ] like that
300 depending on how big the pool is you
know and Willow says nowadays uh kind of
tiny houses are popular yeah I do kind
of feel like there's more like a
downside I think I guess people are kind
of more realizing that you don't need
you don't need all this a bunch of space
that you're not gonna use it's just kind
of gonna sit there and go to waste
depends on what you're doing yeah I mean
it depends on the person it depends on I
mean obviously some people you know need
more space than others but yeah you know
they got guys that have to have badass
garages because they're always in there
building cars or motorcycles which yeah
like I said if you if you have a hobby
that takes up a lot of room then yeah
Camp guy said if I ever get a new house
I'm gonna have a garage type building
where I can put my man cave stuff full
commercial kitchen big three tub
restaurant sink commercial dishwasher
and cooking equipment yeah yeah see but
that's that's kind of like I consider
that kind of like it's a hobby yeah but
that's kind of more practical because
it's like food in Mississippi with guys
had those they would call them Fish
Camps where they would
buy a property around a lake and they'd
all chip in and they'd build a [ __ ]
house out there that had all that kind
of stuff man cave stuff you could
process fish and Duck and it had all the
[ __ ]
all the equipment for fixing vehicles
and boats and motorcycles and
um uh [ __ ] cleaning fish and deer and
had all that [ __ ] and they had rec rooms
and they would chip in like six seven
guys to have this fit built
then as I got older I realized that what
they're really doing is that's what they
were taking their girlfriends because
that's what it really was she's like ooh
take me to the stinky Fish House no they
rarely ever used it for the sneaky house
as well it's the love motel that's what
they were really doing with this [ __ ]
Zach said we had people over uh to my
parents house so rarely that Mom
eventually walled off the dining room
and turned it into my dad's office that
was thing too I kind of feel like that
was
more like a previous generation thing
where a lot of times your house and this
is maybe going back to like the
Victorian era or earlier where a lot of
your house was for like public that was
where like the people you know would
come over to visit you and that there
were public areas of your house you know
what I mean you kind of had to set it up
for those people but I don't know I kind
of feel like now you don't really
[ __ ] need that [ __ ] anymore because
most people don't have people over all
the time they don't yeah
uh Brian hackettlicker hi Tom and Jenny
Brian well hey
Camp guy said large Central pool with
Clubhouse for the whole neighborhood is
the way to go yeah that really seemed to
me
yeah that's that's what we had at the
old place that was like a clubhouse and
there's I wish they'd had a gym too but
they didn't
um some of the my where I used to live
like uh I used to live before we moved
in together I lived in an apartment and
that place had a little a little bitty
gym and a nice big pool and I used to
use that all the time but it's nice
because you can use it and not like have
to worry yeah you're taking care of it
the old place we lived it had a real
nice one had a real nice pool had a
damage uh jacuzzi it had a clubhouse
there [ __ ] super nice looking like
bathroom slash changing rooms and I'd go
down there during the day
get some sun and never would see anybody
else I'd be the only person there yeah
because if you go on a weekday like
everybody's at work or school so you
know there's hardly anybody there it
looks cool it looked just like
I look just like porn you know a lot of
that [ __ ] those porn scenes out at
the pool it's happening here in Florida
and that's just a real generic time
Compares everything everything's good
porn yeah that's that's that's that's
just very generic and that's how that's
how the pools look in Florida
then in the back background you'll see
the same houses and the palm trees and
[ __ ] you know is like that here
Brian says you guys all okay from the
hurricane yeah we uh we actually uh came
out good we didn't have a game or
something like that yeah the only thing
that happened was Power and Water went
out for a little bit for a day yeah like
less than less than 20 hours less than a
day 12 hours yeah something like that so
it was a little tiny bit of a pain it
was nice and cool outside so I could
have slept to the whole [ __ ] thing
yeah probably except it was like I said
it was really really noisy that was the
only thing I had to put I had to put uh
earplugs in because I couldn't because
the wind was so loud that I couldn't
sleep
um yeah Tammy said uh my grandmother had
a good living room only used for
holidays and Company same with the
dining room yeah we had my grandmother's
house had that too she has like had a
small house where I mean as we got older
and started like using that room but
when we were like little kids it was
kind of like the front room which
actually had been a porch originally
like a big porch but they closed it in
like before I was born and turned it
into kind of like
I don't even think they called it yeah I
guess they still call it the living room
but like the front room or whatever it's
funny and you could go in there and hang
out but then there was another living
room that was like the fancy living room
and you weren't really supposed to like
go in there you weren't really supposed
to sit on the couch or anything this is
the funny [ __ ] about that because my
grandmother or my dad said I was just
like that too
these are [ __ ] working class houses
out in the out in the south
they're not impressive on the inside or
outside but but they had
old ladies had the [ __ ] living room
walled off like for the queen in case
the queen shows up yeah you never know
with the fighting and then
nobody ever showed up they never really
[ __ ] used it
as she got older she realized that that
was ridiculous and then she started to
[ __ ] use yeah that's what happened at
ours it's like we would use it on
Christmas and stuff like that's where
she puts the tree and everybody would
come over because
um even old people realized I think is
that they were lied to that nobody wants
to come visit them and if they do come
to visit them they're not going to be
impressed by anything that's in that
house
you I I went back to my aunt's house and
it was [ __ ] untouched from the last
time I saw it in the in the [ __ ] mid
90s and it was nothing like I remembered
it it was exactly the same it was it was
that exactly the same but it was
basically Untouched by time it was like
a time capsule
and it was it was really kind of weird
you're like
this is [ __ ] unchanged basically
there's nothing wrong with it but I was
just it's and it just how dated it was
it was like dated and
irrelevant you know it's like from
another era
and they still [ __ ] love it you know
I mean but it's just kind of funny but
she's not gonna get any guess
you know I don't think you know the
queen is not gonna come over
and anybody that comes visitors somebody
she knows
you know what I mean so yeah and it's
like what's the point if you're friends
with them they shouldn't judge you yeah
I mean they're there all the time like
if Well yeah
if I'm going to my friend's house like
the only thing I'm gonna judge is if the
shit's like filthy you know what I mean
like then I might say something about it
like if they haven't cleaned the
bathroom or something like that it was
just but other than that I'm just kind
of like whatever I don't even care if
it's cluttered or if you got like there
were some cat toys around the floor or
whatever because we have that there were
some of us something about certain
Boomers and above they thought that
there had to be some kind of a formal
room in the house like in case the
president showed up or something well
like I said that's kind of like an old
school that was like back in the old
days like the victorians yeah have like
The Parlor where you would like receive
everybody yeah but I mean it was kind of
like more I mean it was probably
[ __ ] back then too mostly but it was
but I kind of feel like people did go on
more social calls back then because
there wasn't anything else to do
um you know once the TV came along and
then like everything like that like
nobody's gonna bother just like
entertaining themselves by going and
hanging out at your house no more so
that's like that's like the scam of
silverware
silverware companies would invent whole
new menus and whole new things to come
out with a new kind of fork so they
could sell you that and then you have to
[ __ ] sell off all your silverware to
get this new set
that had like new oyster forks and [ __ ]
like that if you didn't have that then
you just weren't proper and this is just
kind of a [ __ ] lower middle class
person buying all this [ __ ] these took a
huge silverware sets yeah because they
got to be fair yeah and they're writing
up all these etiquette books to include
more silverware there's a [ __ ] scam
just got people that believe in that
that there has to be five different
kinds of fork
you know it's a scam a fork is a [ __ ]
Fork I'm like can I stick my food and
get it into my mouth then that's fine
that's the only one the size of the time
the size of the tines don't mean
anything
it's weird though because it's like I'm
not entirely sure I mean I think I'm
sure but it's like yeah even your
standard Walmart
silverware sets that you just buy
whatever have the two sizes of forks
like the long times and the short times
yeah and it's like what is one of those
what is one of those like a dessert fork
or a salad fork or yeah it's one of
salad which one though I don't know I
always use the long time ones yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] the short one doesn't
make any that's what I mean it's there
to sell you more stuff it's not it makes
no difference
the long time one is the one that you
get in a restaurant
yeah
that's all you need that's all you need
I mean you need a short one no
I don't really see the point of the
short one to sell you more [ __ ]
silverware well yeah but like I said you
don't really have much choice because it
just kind of the set comes with that yep
you know and I'm like I don't I don't
really need that yeah cake Fork soup for
soup
sporks yeah uh Zach says did the
bathroom also have fancy soaps that were
for guests only yeah yeah it's fancy
soaps fancy soaps that looks like shells
shells and [ __ ] snails and [ __ ]
butterflies and stupid [ __ ] like that
it's fancy soap and she paid 75 cents
for it and then the and then the towel
and then well the thing is if you have
even if you had guests yeah and then
guess when you use that bathroom they'd
be like oh I I can't use that
stupid so it's like nobody uses it just
sits there for years and years well
because it's same thing like I've been
to people's houses where I legit thought
that like I went in the guest room and I
was like the guest bathroom and it's
like they had all this really nice like
sheep soaps it was all good went with
the theme and everything and then they
had like little themed hand towels and I
was like well oh they look so they look
so pretty I don't want to use it so it's
like that nobody's gonna use it nobody's
gonna use it
and people were [ __ ] cracked it was
just it's just it was just industry
trying to sell [ __ ] consumer products
to people you know and I remember back
in the days just the crazy [ __ ] people
would buy just they'd buy some crazy ass
trinkets like that was gonna do
something for you you know like the very
early computers little Tandy computers
and [ __ ] you can get from Radio Shack
the micro computers like this big
you couldn't do anything with that
nothing
nothing and you spend 100 on that then
it had like a
tape deck drive and didn't come with any
software
and when it did come with some software
it was like some kind of accounting
program that barely worked you could you
could do that on a [ __ ]
piece of paper and put a pencil yeah
this is all kinds of great
today people say computers you know you
got that [ __ ] cell phone that's a bad
[ __ ] Okay the the emperor of
Rome would have [ __ ] been you know
impressed with hell you know it's
impressed to [ __ ] with that thing it'd
be the most powerful thing he'd ever
seen
and everybody's got one and everybody's
got one pretty much but back in the day
when computers first arrived there was
no software for them so you really
couldn't do anything with them they were
they didn't seem I wouldn't think that
that was going to go anywhere until I
saw a apple 2E computer and that [ __ ]
I saw the video games on Apple 2E and
it's far better than Atari the Atari
2600 at the time
and I was like yeah that computer though
you know there's something to that
they're playing Wizardry and [ __ ] on
there Wizardry too
Apple 2E
I remember I was fantasizing about an
apple 2E but I remember using those at
school yeah like when I was little yeah
I was like that was the first computer
you could actually use yeah I must have
been eight yeah when we started using
that after that they were [ __ ]
useless to the average person
Zach says oh my God my mom and my aunt
almost went to court over a China set my
grandma left one of them in her well
that I'm pretty sure came from a catalog
yeah
it's really sad to me like how because
this same thing kind of happened when my
grandmother died yeah all the [ __ ] you
throw away no that wasn't what I was
gonna say all right what I was gonna say
if you'd let me finish was that um
suddenly all of the relatives come out
of the woodwork wanting this that and
the other thing okay which hide
everything yeah yeah and I was just kind
of like man that's not cool I you know
they want her [ __ ] yeah the um they just
descend like vultures and it's like I
was like I was really really uh
disillusioned by that whole thing when
my grandmother kicked a bucket
she had a whole bunch of those damn
collectors plates
that she was convinced were worth
something yeah The infomercials The
infomercials told her were they Gone
With the Wind oh yeah that was one of
them there was a bunch of them one of
them was gone I remember the guy had a
[ __ ] ton of these damn collector's
plates
they came with a certificate of
authenticity and everything okay
she died those [ __ ] they went
all into the garbage can
I kind of feel like that's mostly what
happens yeah I mean with that kind of
stuff yeah
directly into the garbage can and they
were like you're [ __ ] this old lady's
[ __ ] prized possessions and [ __ ]
I mean the thing about it is like if you
know if you want to spend your money on
whatever you want and if you want them
on your wall and they make you happy
then that's fine yeah but like just
don't expect them to be worth anything
or like collectors or anything like that
I don't really that's the only thing
like I said if you just like them if you
just like them and want to look at them
every day then that's fine yeah my dad
was like aren't those supposed to be
worth a bunch of money and I went no no
the only person would pay pay anything
for those to be an old lady and those
old ladies are all dying off
I mean [ __ ] you can go to like every
Goodwill in America and there's like
stacks of them this ain't worth nothing
and I said this is what they were
getting like a quarter of a piece or
something he goes this aren't worth
anything and I said this is what it's
worth I'll [ __ ] grab the thing I'll
do that [ __ ] in the [ __ ] garbage can
he laughed as he started throwing them
off taking them off the wall and thought
a boy
says don't put that in there because it
became you know became his house so it
started to get direct decorated like a
guy lived there you know
so
which I will probably I might inherit
that house when he goes but what am I
gonna do with that I want to live out
there it's out in the middle [ __ ]
nowhere
by rights it goes to Krista next but I
don't think she wants it
well yeah like you said what are you
gonna do with it I'm there it's not like
you could eat I don't even think my
cousins want it that's what I mean even
if you got it like and you could sell it
like who would buy it
foreign
the roof has got to be leaking somewhere
as old as that house is
I wouldn't live out there
nothing out there that's what I'm saying
be depressed as [ __ ] living out there
said pet rock the epitome of something
to waste money on yeah although I have
to say I admire uh I admire the guy that
invented that that he got all those
people to like pay all that money for
essentially a rock so good for him The
Collector Plate things was just
something old ladies would buy and
they'd look at them and [ __ ] feel
like they had something so I guess they
were kind of like a little emotional
things you know which I guess a lot of
people do that kind of stuff well that's
what I mean like I got all kind of like
fun little monsters and stuff like that
back there I just like them they make me
happy I don't I don't think that I don't
think they're gonna be like worth
anything oh she thought they were worth
something see that's what I mean you
know she loved she thought they were
worse I just get them because I like
them I was looking at them things you
know what I mean [ __ ] back when I
smoked they'd sit there [ __ ] smoking
like that looking at the [ __ ] thing
she's plate she's looking at she goes oh
yeah this is a rare one there was only a
thousand made and I'm looking at that
thing and I'm going you'd never be able
to get a buyer for that so any [ __ ]
I didn't tell her that though
Ben says Franklin Mint got sued in
Australia yeah I know that's what he's
saying yeah uh got sued in Australia for
their limited edition plates yeah which
were limited to a certain number of
firing days so if they needed more they
could just whip up another bag yeah how
many were needed right that's what I'm
saying so they can always just kind of
like yeah ooh limited like we only did
this many which yeah no and and I bet
you if you looked up values of any of
those but you couldn't even find the
values because there isn't any
that was just some kind of scam
Athena said hey y'all in North Carolina
getting ready to build a [ __ ] Ark
it's raining and blowing yeah and there
you get in the next uh the next wave of
that [ __ ] yeah so good luck man that was
[ __ ] shitty like I said it is mostly
weakened by the time it got to us but it
was still pretty bad and then like it
went back in the ocean and like
strengthened back up again so now it's
like gonna kick the ass of like is it
out there again yeah okay well yeah as
soon as it went back out into the
Atlantic it strengthened back up to a
hurricane again because it was over the
water it's not changing direction is it
it's not gonna come back is it you got
to watch because that we've had ones do
that before like we've had one I can't
remember what year it was I don't it was
that before you came here maybe but we
had one that like went through the
middle of Florida and they were like
shoot that's gone and then it [ __ ]
turned around and came back
somebody doing me
jeez I know I'm not sick either it's the
[ __ ] that I'm on
um
somebody do me a favor and go look at
Franklin Mint
and Google that [ __ ] and see a friend
that Franklin meant plates are worth
anything I bet you they're not yeah Ben
said look at them on eBay yeah he's on
eBay looking at him well no it said uh
somebody should go look at him yeah I
bet you there's nothing I mean I'd be
curious like to see if any of them were
worth anything but I just I highly doubt
it I was I remember even at the at the
tender age of 16 17 watching them down
Franklin Mint commercials
starting to smell [ __ ] going like
if that [ __ ] is such some some if that
[ __ ] is so rare and valuable and
collectible what the [ __ ] is it doing
you know what I mean on in a TV
commercial sandwiched in between these
[ __ ] soap operas
you know what I mean well yeah that's
what I'm saying I was like no well and
they always it was always and I think it
was also the Franklin Mint that had all
those like commemorative coins and all
that kind of stuff junk and they're and
they always like talked about how
[ __ ] valuable they were and I'm just
like well how about how valuable can
they be if you're selling them on like
an infomercial yeah I've never seen
anything that was worth anything sold on
a damn infomercial no it's always some
kind of fake trinket type thing or some
like weird Gadget yeah it cuts tomatoes
you know it's a metaphor remember that
[ __ ] the pedophor the salad pedophor the
[ __ ] what a pedophore is like a
little cake like that yeah I remember
yeah what was it didn't they call it a
pedophore I have no idea I have no idea
what you're talking there's a tool you
could put it
uh you guys might correct me it was a
long time when I was a little kid
there's a tool you could put on a
vegetable and do like this that had a
wire and it would cut it into a dam into
like a flower yeah into like a rose yeah
I remember you talking about but I don't
remember what that was I thought it was
called a some rather a pedophil or
something or other
I don't know maybe it was but I don't
remember yeah it was called it was
[ __ ] so you could make like a fancy
curly salad yeah yeah yeah that's that's
I just have a very vague memory of
and they were doing that to tomatoes and
carrots and hard-boiled eggs and pickles
and [ __ ]
making fancy pickles the crazy thing
though is that the As Seen On TV
um kind of thing is still going strong
like we I've been in malls recently that
had a whole As Seen On TV store and
actually one of my graphic designer
clients
um his whole business is those like he
has like these As Seen On TV things and
my job is to like take some of the [ __ ]
that you see on As Seen On TV stuff and
like
they basically buy the um the product
from like the same manufacturer but then
you can like name it yourself you can
have your own box design you can have
your own packaging and your own kind of
like advertising campaign but it's all
like the same thing you know what I mean
so he'll so he'll like send me a thing
and it's like hey this is like
you know that thing that uh that boils
the eggs and the little silicone deal
whatever or the little uh baked potato
jackets that you put in the microwave or
whatever and it's like you know they're
selling one called the potato coat or
whatever the [ __ ] the name is I don't
know what it is but he's like but I'm
calling mine the whatever and he's like
here's pictures of it and here's like
and they want a new box design looks
like Sly wants to show up out of blue
how you been Sly said love your red hair
Jenny thank you very much Ben said but
they have the official authorized Museum
of the American Indian in the official
Institute of the old west and Etc yeah
Adriana was saying that they're worth
between eight hundred and seventy
dollars I guarantee you [ __ ] they're
not getting no 7.99 7.99 to 77.77 okay
so it's not worth anything so I'm
guessing out of defend granpter says
Grand Theft is a married couple with no
kids who covered their walls with Winnie
the Pooh and Disney ornamental plates
well there is that whole subculture
known as Disney adults that are just
really like into Disney stuff which like
I said everybody's into their own thing
I don't care
they're not hurting anybody
I guarantee you Franklin Mint plate
ain't worth [ __ ] and most of them are
probably super common
and then there's no buyers
that's a problem
there are comic books out there
that are appraised in millions of
dollars but you'll never get a buyer
you know just because the fans are all
dead
you know Superman number one Action
Comics number one is always going to
worth a lot to get worth be worth a lot
you know it's got Superman on it first
time Superman appeared but there's a lot
of other ones that were numb you know
you know [ __ ] number one you know of
something you know Meteor Man or some
[ __ ] like that and at one time
worth about a million dollars
but the guys that were into that are
gone they're gone now so the younger
guys don't want to buy that
they had a million they'd buy something
else
so I think the Franklin Mint plates are
going to be something like that
man man man that's right that's a good
that's a good superhero
there was a whole Mystery Science
Theater sketch about like man man that's
a good one about weird like superheroes
man band was one man always smells like
Maple man there was like a few other
ones they can't remember what oh it
smells like Maple yeah
okay I'm trying to think of that dude
always smells like [ __ ] the pheasant
plucker and the pheasant plucker son
like they were coming up I like man I do
too that was my favorite one that's why
I remembered it
laughs
grandma said uh the time life books were
another waste the Cowboys the
railroaders yeah the Pioneers the
seafarers I did like the covers of them
they were only good to read but they
weren't collectors thanks my dad had
some of those but they were just good to
read yeah that's what I mean like we had
some of them too and it's like I just
thought they were pretty and I thought
they were interesting I didn't really
actually think they were working
I don't think well maybe they were maybe
maybe they had some because I checked
some out of the library because I feel
like didn't they do like a paranormal
series there was like ghost stories and
stuff because I remember I didn't buy
them obviously but I checked them out of
the library and I remember they were
they were actually like nice quality
books like they had nice covers and they
were all like full color inside and
there was one that they did that was
kind of I think it was called man myth
and the Occult or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah I remember that one that was a
good one yeah it was blue yeah we had
some I read some of those yeah yeah like
I said I just got them when you were a
kid it had spooky [ __ ] in it yeah called
man myth in the occult or something like
that yeah I know what you're talking
about but I can't remember
in a long time yeah I remember what
you're talking about though and I
remember seeing the commercials for it
they have a whole book on Voodoo and
another yeah I read the voodoo yeah and
he had another book like on [ __ ]
Satanism and deep demonism yeah another
one on ghosts
Ben says I think they were a peace work
Series where people would order them one
at a time from the news agent and if
there was enough demand they would keep
churning them out yeah I kind of feel
like that's probably what happened like
they I don't know if they did like a
whole series but they would just like do
a limited run of some and then if they
sold out then they would keep doing them
probably
I don't know but like I said they were
those at least had some kind of value to
them because like I said they were books
and they were interesting and
you know you could read them and yeah
[ __ ] a point
pretty much
Zach said I would go to court over a
ring with our last initial in it that
goes through the met on my dad's side
black onyx and gold it's made from that
it's really pretty I yeah I think I know
I've seen a ring kind of like that I
think I know what you're talking about
uh and Ben said some of the seafarers
books are really interesting yeah I mean
honestly you know I can't really get on
anybody's case about like buying books
because I have a lot well that was in a
time that was in a time before the
internet and you could sell
encyclopedias they had people run around
selling encyclopedias because there was
no internet so it was like having your
own Library you could refer to real
quickly
and those Time Life books about the old
west and this and that I guess they were
kind of the sales technique was they
were like well we could sell these kind
of like you sell
uh encyclopedias you know I want to you
know each want to be on a certain
subject for your own Library which there
was back in those days I think that's
probably
a decent sell they could you could
probably sell a lot of them because they
didn't they couldn't find that
information online yeah and you didn't
want to go to the library all the time
so you just did that but I remember the
I remember those books were
I don't want to say they were thin they
were just very very basic they were easy
they were easy reading you could read
through them you know in a few hours you
know
um
but they had a lot of photographs in
them reference photographs kind of like
owning reference books in a certain way
they were all right especially when you
were a kid yeah I remember really liking
them like I said I don't think we owned
any but I used to get them out of the
library all the time
Michael Schaefer said the invention of
the CD-ROM drive killed the print
encyclopedia industry yeah yeah I
remember back in 1995 or 1996 when we
got like our first Windows computer like
the desktop computer we'd had like
little ones prior to that yeah um we got
that CD it might have come with the
computer the CD-ROM that had like the
one volume encyclopedia and we were like
what it's like a whole [ __ ]
encyclopedia on like one disc you know
what I mean
Scientology was jumping on print like oh
we better [ __ ] start printing all
these damn [ __ ] books [ __ ] funny
because they get they'd get the damn
print technology then they got CD-ROM
and CD technology I tried to sell CDs in
an era of MP3
one generation behind it does seem like
because they can get that [ __ ]
technology cheap they'd start producing
it
[ __ ] scientists well and they know
that they have like a you know kind of a
captive audience yes and if slave labor
force
yeah jeffreyard said the books we're
talking about are time life's mysteries
of the unknown yeah
that's it yeah I really do I really dug
those because I really like those kind
of like Anthology Style
reference books I still have some
I don't have any of those but I do have
some I have one that's like Greek
mythology
I have one like that's uh I think it was
Reader's Digest but it's like a big
hardback and it has all kind of stuff
like it's uh it has Supernatural [ __ ]
but it also has like history and like
weird history and all kind of stuff like
it's a really big compilation and I
still like that book
um I remembered that there was something
like man myth and Magic maybe that yeah
I think that's what it was man myth and
met I think that's what it was called
because I remember it was alliterative
like it was awesome was that the name of
the series or was that name of one of
the books in the series I think that was
the whole series because it was man myth
and magic and then like you said there
was I remember the voodoo one because I
remember reading that one
and there was one on
[Music]
what the [ __ ] there was yeah they were
all oh God damn it the voodoo one is the
main the main one I remember for
whatever reason but there was like a
bunch of different ones but Mysteries of
the unknown I think that was more like
the ghost ones
you know yeah and then that one was kind
of like the more occult stuff if I
remember it correctly
yeah Michael Schaefer said they were
like the print version of the show in
search of exactly exactly exactly which
is why I really dug out and when you
were a kid they were creepy yeah creepy
pictures in them and [ __ ] yeah whoa
so like I said I kind of feel like that
you get a lot more value out of that I
don't even remember how much they were
to be honest with you I don't know I
think they're probably like five dollars
a copy yeah that's what I was gonna say
I think they were like 4.99 or something
but or what they would do is I think
what they would do is they'd give you
like the first one for 4.99 and then
like they'd send you a new one like
every month but it would be like 14.99
you know what I mean so it was just kind
of like a subscription that you had to
cancel kind of like the [ __ ]
what was that that what was that thing
where uh
God damn it
God I can't remember anything tonight
what the [ __ ] is the matter of me I'm
like not even drunk or anything and I
still can't remember anything got little
uh it's a [ __ ] I don't know I don't
know what it is was the storm like
stress me out and I'm all [ __ ]
my [ __ ] brain's all addled uh
Columbia house that's what I was trying
to think of Columbia house uh for for
you youngsters was that
um well it was cassettes in my day but
you got they'd send you
10 for a penny I think
and then later it was CDs but they'd
send you 10 for a penny but then like
every month you had to pay I think it
was 9.99 and then they'd send you you
could either pick one or if you didn't
pick one which happened to me a few
times and I'm sure which happened to
most people which is how they made all
their money then they would just send
you whatever the selection was so that's
how come I ended up with like a bunch of
shitty CDs that I didn't want was
because I just kept like forgetting to
pick a good one and they didn't really
have a lot of good ones to pick from
like if you were
if you are into like weirder music you
know it was they just had like real
mainstream stuff so which is which is
fine for a couple of things but
you know if you if you wanted something
a little more weird like they didn't
really have anything yeah Columbia
record Club that's right
I kind of remember like the tail end of
it I remember that they the vinyl one
but I kind of feel like when I was old
enough
to be thinking about doing it it was
cassettes so I did get actually get some
but usually I remembered like I would I
would do it I would cheat well I think a
lot of people did this where you'd get
like your 10 for a penny
and then I think they made you have like
one more month if I'm not mistaken and
then you would pick like one other good
one and then you would cancel it so then
you'd essentially get like 11
like things for you know 10 bucks which
not bad at all not bad at all so
considering that cassettes back then
were [ __ ]
10 bucks just for one
uh Mark said I can hear Leonard Nimoy
reading them out loud right now
I know
they were so cool it's just like I don't
know I have really really fond memories
of uh going to the library back in the
day and always like looking in the
spooky ghost story section you know what
I mean and getting all those kind of
books seeing what was in there let's try
the beer
yeah so look at this I I went down to
Publix today
to get some [ __ ] and look I found these
I don't know if they're any good this is
Rebel hard coffee pumpkin spice latte
pumpkin spice latte coffee with beer
Malt Beverages smokers with malt
beverage inside okay so it's coffee beer
okay I just saw it in Publix and it was
on sale for like 560. oh hell yeah is it
good yeah it's better than that beer oh
okay yeah it's real good let's check it
out I just saw it while I was walking by
and I was like huh okay real nice 569 I
could slam them
in big trouble it smells good you
already might get in big trouble getting
big trouble
oh my God
that's good that's delightful Rebel it's
called Rebel huh
that doesn't eat that barely tastes
alcoholic
gotta be careful because it
that's what I thought about that
that Bacardi mojito [ __ ] yeah but you
drank like 10 of those yeah I got
[ __ ] slammed on it yeah you did you
were like [ __ ] yeah slopping all over
the place I don't know what the what's
the um what's the alcohol I can't
[ __ ] see it's probably about like a
beer it's too dark in here
I mean I like that it's dark in here but
I can't [ __ ] read [ __ ] I don't know I
don't know what it says
yeah that's actually really good I'm
gonna have to get those again I just saw
it while I was wandering by and I was
just kind of like oh okay and why not
why not
make it feel like fall because
tomorrow's the first of October gravity
is going on about
old school Playboy he's got a bunch of
them back when them women were naturally
beautiful and I almost called [ __ ]
on the on that a lot of them girls were
not natural and then a lot of them were
airbrushed there was a lot of uh
photographic trickery in Old School
Playboy
um they would do weird [ __ ] like we had
the girl kind of stand a little bit
sideways they have to [ __ ] tape up on
her boob make her boob look a little bit
bigger that's one of the things and
another thing is is that people forget
that
silicone implantation of different kinds
including silicone infusion
was around since the [ __ ] late 40s
so it's hard to know who's natural and
who isn't if somebody impressed you
know those old photographs a lot of
times they might not have been totally
natural
in those days he didn't have to get
[ __ ] implants they could just inject
silicone right into a woman
well like I said nowadays I don't know
well I was gonna say they don't bother
with it but I think they still do
because it just makes the Photoshop
person's job easier but when you're
doing like an expensive photo shoot then
yeah you're gonna have all kind of tape
and you're gonna have like all kind of
because they're gonna try and make it
look as good as possible within the
parameters but they know that later on
like the Photoshop person's gonna fix it
yeah so but even back even back in the
70s they were using filter yeah I'm just
saying they could do all that kind of
stuff they're taking photographs of
photographs
you take a photograph and you blow it up
then you use airbrushing to change that
photograph and then [ __ ] lay that out
under perfect conditions and photograph
that [ __ ] photograph and now you got
another copy of it and it's modded a
bunch of [ __ ] that you can do that they
used to do back then
yeah it's not I know people talk about
like Photoshop nowadays and it certainly
is a lot easier but they can do all kind
of like trickery back then too yeah and
like I said it's not just
photographic stuff it was stuff to do
with like you know taping things
everywhere and like [ __ ] having them
pose a certain way like you know if you
stand this way like you look skinnier
and all this other kind of stuff you
know what I mean it's the same thing
with the dudes
you'd have those [ __ ] athletic
looking [ __ ] running around and
go oh man that [ __ ] that's
before steroids no
testosterone [ __ ] propionate was
available in 1937. you could buy it in
1937 get it reliably and it wasn't that
expensive and they took it
um
by the time the 50s were rolling around
they could get Deanna ball
and and really all you had to do is ask
for it there was no
um it was over the counter you know so
they had all that
Michael Schaefer said Penthouse he used
to use a lens that was a little blurry
yeah I do kind of feel like well even
like you're soft yeah the porn films
back in the old days well that's kind of
the thing and I feel like nowadays it's
a little bit harder because you know
everything's HD so you can see
everybody's [ __ ] pores and everything
like that so everybody has I mean yeah
they have like better makeup and better
[ __ ] like these filters though and they
use digital filters and stuff like that
but yeah I kind of feel like back in the
day it's just kind of like well it's
literally yeah we don't want anybody to
see like the pimples on her ass or
anything like that so we're just gonna
like blur the [ __ ] [ __ ] A lot of
those girls look rough I mean there was
[ __ ] drugs involved you know I mean
the girls are [ __ ] snorting cocaine
and [ __ ] A lot of them look real hard
yeah well isn't that like when they used
to do do you remember like that that
shop in the mall that used to do like
the kind of Boudoir yeah photographs
what the [ __ ] is the name of that place
um you might be talking about Glamor
Shots yeah glamorous shots there you go
Glamor Shots that wasn't the only kind
they did but yeah so they would always
use that soft focused lens yeah that
sucks put makeup on them ugly girls get
them pretty
and they had all those clothes that they
put on you like they put the [ __ ]
terrible ass [ __ ] clothes put a
cowboy hat on a girl well that was well
yeah I guess yeah cowboy has to I kind
of felt like that was that was kind of
more like if you go to like a tourist
area and like dress up like a cowboy or
like a like a saloon hooker or something
crazy [ __ ] though but yeah the ones out
there it's like they'd usually put on a
[ __ ] uh like a feather boa or some
[ __ ] like that yeah well because it will
remember like the Glamor Shots because I
remember there was like commercials and
I remember there being a Glamor Shots in
our mall like in the 80s and you know
back in the 80s glamor meant we're gonna
make your hair like this big and
everything's gonna have like sequins and
feathers and big shoulder pads and yeah
[ __ ] purple eyeshadow or like blue
eyeshadow on it it's like the terrible
eye shadow back in the day the one thing
that they did do and I think it was like
limited time I don't even think that
many people did it but it's like that
was the only time that I actually would
have considered going was they did like
um like an old Hollywood line so you
could go and they would do you they do
your hair like the 40s and like they
would take like black and white like old
school like Glamor Shots of you and I
was like now see that's a good idea
it's like I don't want to look like have
my [ __ ] hair teased out to here with
like 40. it's like shining with with
crackling hairspray and then like they
put a top on you that was like all
[ __ ] shimmery and like that kind of
crazy [ __ ] I didn't want that but I did
like that I did like the old school
glamor one they did for a while
uh Adriana said Jenny did you collect
paperbacks from hell I've seen them up
to a hundred dollars on eBay each and
most of them were forgotten
um I never did I probably had some but I
think that they you know are sadly lost
now
um if you haven't read the book is by
Grady Hendricks which is called
paperbacks from hell
and um he talks all about that era like
in horror of all the you know uh the
paperback Originals of which there are a
lot of them but like yeah like a lot of
them were really good and a lot of them
were forgotten about and yeah it's like
really and honestly that's kind of how I
came across ended up coming across
Michael Mcdowell
um who I ended up really liking and I
hadn't heard I didn't hear of him back
in the day and I only heard of him like
recently even though he's the dude that
like wrote Beetlejuice and all this
other kind of stuff and he wrote like
all these really really cool like horror
novels back in the 80s
um that were paperback originals and
then he just kind of got forgotten about
until about 2014 and then valencourt
books started putting out his stuff from
back then but there was a lot of good
[ __ ] because horror was big like in the
70s and 80s like particularly in the
wake of Stephen King and everything like
that so like there was a glut
of horror in the market and like I said
a lot of it was kind of shitty but a lot
of them were really good too and a lot
of those authors just kind of got
forgotten about because they didn't you
know they didn't get published in
hardback or anything like that it was
just like little cheap paperbacks like
you'd buy at the drugstore or whatever
and you know just like they did with
westerns and romances and all that kind
of stuff
bacina said I had a pair of the original
Dr Scholl's shoes oh my god did they
still make Dr Scholl's stuff yeah I
guess they do the one with the hump in
the middle for your toes a whole lot too
they made your legs sore and you that
you sounded like a 40 mare when you
walked I don't remember
I don't know I didn't know any about
those
Michael Schaefer said big hair was
[ __ ] awesome I do like big death Rock
hair I do I do like that it is yeah like
you know in big Mohawks and like kind of
the Big T's like old school Susie and
the Banshees I like that I don't really
like the big curly yeah thing that long
hair at the time well I don't I don't
and well the teenage girls were doing it
too like this really really big like
curly hair and like you put so much
spray in it that it kind of was like
hard yeah like you could see like pieces
of it and it was just like hard
um I didn't like that but even though I
probably did it a few times yeah I'm a
brother
I probably did it a few times
that's good what's the matter with you
nothing oh okay just kind of catching up
with me this is pretty good though
yeah I'm actually the this is probably
like the best one that we've had of
these of all these pumpkins because this
actually does it tastes like it tastes
like a pumpkin spice latte yeah it
tastes like what they claim it to be
it's because they don't they didn't have
to brew it there's no beer in it yeah
they just adds some of that damn
Malt Liquor in there and that's damn
that [ __ ] has no flavor really
so that's the thing I liked the ones
that we got before but the ones before
like were very beer forward yeah and
then like you could kind of taste like a
little bit of coffee pumpkin spice on
the back end whereas this definitely
tastes like a pumpkin spice latte yeah
that maybe has alcohol in it yeah you
know
hey Sly man I don't know if you saw it
but a couple weeks back I did a Colt 45
taste test all right [ __ ] I was
evoking I was evoking the spirit of
[ __ ] Billy D Williams man he was
[ __ ] with me right there [ __ ]
right alongside me drinking that cold
45.
I hadn't had his I hadn't had it since
the Army I tell all kinds of Barrett
stories about their brothers trying to
make white boys drink [ __ ] cold 45.
that and some of those other ones
[ __ ] bull what was it [ __ ] what
was the bull I forgot what was that [ __ ]
called
and I got into it on a program
they were trying to revoke my white boy
card for drinking that [ __ ]
but I remembered it being better than
[ __ ] bud I was like I remember this
being better
dollar for dollar then that [ __ ] piss
water Budweiser
and I bought that [ __ ] and did a whole
show on it did two sep two separate ones
of Colt 45 Colt 45 regular and I did
Colt 45 high gravity
High Gravity came in a classy [ __ ]
black [ __ ] cab
yeah they were good man real good for
the price
you know for the price yeah I didn't
mind them at all yeah they were good I
could drink that if I only had a dollar
or something
to spend on a can on a canned beer I'd
rather take that [ __ ] coal 45 if I
could Budweiser any day
that's it was drinkable it was an
enjoyable experience but [ __ ] piss
water
Michael Schaefer said Tom try the
greater pumpkin ale if you get a chance
it's aged in Bourbon barrels and you can
just get a hint of the bourbon with the
pumpkin spice
this is Jenny's operation I'm not real
wed to this idea that something has to
taste like pumpkin
you know
I like the pumpkin spice that was pretty
well I just thought because it was fall
and I was like I said I was at Publix
getting some other stuff I've got some
orange juice and I got you some diet
root beer and [ __ ] like that then I said
oh I'm gonna take a little cruise down
the bureau because I was too lazy to go
to the liquor store
so I said I'm gonna take a cruise down
the beer aisle and see what now they're
talking about Mickey's big mouth I
remember that one Mickey's yeah
that was Malt Liquor too they make that
anymore yeah it's around I saw it
I saw it
I saw it up the redneck red next door
where is that redneck store
you know how you come out here and you
head towards public so you go straight
yeah you go all the way down to the
light and turn right yeah okay
no on when I make that right turn you
know JJ's that bar is right there yeah
next to it
here's the [ __ ] red next door oh okay
right there oh we've passed it before
right yes at all times oh okay yeah yeah
okay I didn't realize that was though
you must be a card carrying redneck to
set foot in that [ __ ] I'll pass
and another fat girls working in there
[ __ ] yell at you when you see there he
is
what you looking for
there he is I'm like there he is here I
am yeah I mean I hope here I am you
looking for code 45 again
she's funny oh Lord [ __ ] I call her
Large Marge she kind of remind me of
large margin then she was a kid she's
[ __ ] 20 something maybe 30.
she's [ __ ] funny did she drive a
truck and like turn toward your
interview short
chick
heavy set it's almost be polite you know
why start now I was I got it
I'm in public but that place is [ __ ]
stacked to the rafters with [ __ ]
booze of all [ __ ] descriptions none
of it any kind of order
that yeah that tracks yeah
the aisles are two feet wide and it's
nothing but [ __ ] cases of [ __ ] yeah I
can imagine you're gonna walk in there
like that yeah
yeah trying not to like knock stuff off
with your elbows they got the [ __ ]
heavy bulletproof glass up in there when
they're definitely shot guns and [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the other side there oh I'm sure
definitely I'm sure yeah
I mean to be honest with you though like
we started going to that the other day
and then I was like hey there's an ABC
Liquor right there and that ABC is like
all classy as well yeah because that's
like in a really nice that's that classy
that's it's classy yeah it's huge that
ABC you're always kind of nice stuff you
will lose biker points if they see you
in ABC that's okay
I'm not worried about it I gotta
represent up in this [ __ ] okay I was
down there today
I need to [ __ ] stop by JJ's and leave
my scent mark on [ __ ] JJ's one of
these days too what you mean you're
gonna like rub your butt on it I don't
know what it is just be showing up he's
gonna just me showing up I just had a
really funny mental image walking into
there just like rubbing his butt off
that's what they're doing that's what
they're doing
you go in there you go in there and it's
[ __ ] it looks like it was made in the
[ __ ] 80s all the rooms are [ __ ]
square
[ __ ] the bars are just on one side
and they got [ __ ] air hockey tables
and pool tables and [ __ ] in there
air hockey I like air hockey air hockey
yes I think it was air hockey
it's my memories yeah they said me and
my brother used to play it yeah at Chuck
E cheese or whatever yeah
she was [ __ ] bikers [ __ ] as [ __ ]
biker redneck [ __ ]
I don't know how I don't know how
redneck air hockey is as I don't know
about the main biker redneck bar that's
up the street from [ __ ] The Oasis
that's the that's the central hub
Central hub
of redneckery yeah that's the bar that
Arnold's the T that the Arnold
Schwarzenegger as the Terminator went in
Terminator 2 to go get the motorcycle
you know the bad of the bone one that
that's that but cheaper cheaper looking
yeah yeah
cheaper and more authentic looking
that's what I always imagine yeah well
because like I said I grew up in Daytona
Beach I've seen many many bars like that
like the circus yeah you can see [ __ ]
we're at my friend's dad worked in there
so I was in there like you can see used
up rock head [ __ ] girls in there and
[ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] it I kind
of feel like the shitty one in Daytona
it wasn't necessarily a redneck bar it
was more like well it was kind of a
redneck bar because kind of everything
was in Daytona back then but it was also
a strip club I think what was it called
the shark Lounge yeah the shark Lounge
I don't remember if I ever went in no
baby I did
maybe I did go in there one time I don't
remember what the situation was I must
have been with some people that were
like hey let's go on the shark round and
I was like whatever Michael said is at
the corner of client and Dixie
oh yeah probably yeah yeah
he says Tom with his butt on the carpet
dragging himself across the floor with
his hands like a dog yeah yeah I kind of
I kind of pictured him walking in and
just him going up to the corner of the
bar and then just like turning around
and rubbing his butt against it like
like he was twerking that's what that's
what I pictured
that's what I pictured it's funny that
she it's fine did you say that
it's funny that you say that because
today you were in the Barts working
weren't you no no no it's funny that you
know you say [ __ ] clan in Dixie
Street because I remember when I first
when I first started going there after a
while I was going like I guess black
people don't come here but then
eventually [ __ ] no black people did
show up there were bikers though and uh
yeah they were they fit in along with
everybody else if you got a motorcycle
and you look right you're not gonna have
any [ __ ] problem they don't really
care what race you are as long as you're
a [ __ ] biker
I'll imagine if you were black and you
were all right you know you could
probably go in there you know what I
mean certain hours see I've never been
in there on Friday and Saturday night
and they say you're not really supposed
to go in there on Friday and Saturday if
you catch the faces got [ __ ] cameras
everywhere you know I mean [ __ ]
people have been [ __ ] shot the [ __ ]
up in there you know
over the years sounds like a blast some
they fighting you know they're gonna
they're gonna do what they gotta do and
a lot of it I think it happens out in
the parking lot
according to the rumors
it doesn't really happen in there it
happens out in the parking lot they
start going out there and they start
fighting in there and then they kick
them out and they go in the parking lot
and then they continue to fight and
[ __ ] will pull Gods on each
other and [ __ ] shoot the place up and
[ __ ]
probably and see the people like get
them they'd probably not hit anything
too you know it just depends they're
probably all drunk yeah
I
saw you looking at her titties that kind
of [ __ ] you know
then you look at the girl they're
talking about and she weighs 300 pounds
you know it's gonna be some crazy [ __ ]
like that
dumb [ __ ]
well what else is new yeah
I don't go down there I'll go down there
Friday Saturday
that [ __ ]
we're gonna go to the [ __ ] real Club
you know what I mean that [ __ ] there no
that's weekday stuff or set or Saturday
and Sunday afternoon with all the
motorcycles are out that's where you go
yeah and it's older crowd but uh
weekends is supposed to be a younger
crowd and they're dumb
yeah this would be pretty dumb
those are the ones that can't get out of
town I guess I don't know
Robert said I think my best friend's
exorcism is now on Amazon it is I just
saw today and so
um I'm going to watch it in the next
couple days and then I'm gonna review it
probably on Thursday because I've been
wanting to see it for a really long it
better be good God damn it because that
book was [ __ ] excellent
so yeah I was thinking about it too and
I don't even remember
how I thought about it today oops I saw
somebody like review like I saw like an
ad like somebody reviewing it I was like
oh is that up and it's like oh goody
because I haven't wanted to see that for
a really long time I love that book
mango said in the next week hobgoblin
will have their pumpkin ale out for
Halloween here uh and Jeff yard said
Dogfish Head has a pumpkin ale that
actually tastes like pumpkin pie I think
we saw that when we were at um
at uh ABC liquor but we didn't buy that
one made with cinnamon and real pumpkin
meal yeah I mean I
I don't know it's like I said because
the weather doesn't change that much
here so I always try to like try to do
fall things because I really like fall
it's my favorite season
and so I get real I know it's very basic
[ __ ] but I I just really like all the
pumpkin spice stuff I need pumpkin [ __ ]
all of like all year round I don't care
but you know
you can't really get you can't really
get it otherwise I saw Schaefer you're
right man [ __ ] that
murder Hornets [ __ ] hidden I guess he
wasn't here to hear what's going on yeah
girl 300 pounds but they're still
titties yeah that's right yeah titties
are titties they're still titties
they're [ __ ] fighting over some
300 pound girl
because she's the only one that's around
yeah only one with teeth
yeah well that too yeah you only grow
with teeth yeah
Mark says Blair Witch 2 is on prime it
is unwatchably bad you know what I kind
of have a soft spot for Blair Witch too
I don't really know why I haven't seen
it in a really long time but I remember
seeing it
when it first came out and then like I
saw it again after I might have bought
it on DVD I don't remember I didn't like
Blair Witch one well like I told you
before Blair Witch 2 is not different
you're good it's not found footage okay
um I might like it then who knows a lot
of people hate it but I I haven't seen
it in a long time though to be fair
um but I remember liking it being like
what that's not bad at all but you know
what I mean I can remember the 90s when
Blair Witch 1 came out
that was when I was with my first wife
and then head down there and passed
Christian Mississippi and we had a good
little band to damn goth
kids you know they were I was not a kid
I was I was in my mid middle late 20s
but they were I guess I was a kid
they were younger than me
and there was something about it was the
beginnings of the internet
and we heard about the Blair Wick
project on the internet before we ever
yeah it was really one of the best uh
online campaigns they were way ahead of
the timeline and me being the wise goth
who's sitting here trying to analyze
what I didn't really have a full grasp
of what multimedia was you know and we
thought it might be something real
something that had really happened I
remember being kind of excited about it
in a certain way like that's some creepy
[ __ ]
and um Melissa was thinking no no it's
based on something that really happened
you know well yeah that's how they
Market it yeah and we we could we could
talk about that [ __ ] for hours we were
[ __ ]
eating that damn or drinking [ __ ] uh
cricket ass glasses yeah
I'm gonna show y'all who I'm talking
about
I'm gonna show y'all who I'm talking
whoever said it had a great concept I
think but it's definitely a product of
its time it's so thousands it hurts yeah
that's the thing it's like like I said I
haven't seen it in a long time and
I'm not a fan yeah and I want to like
say this across the board because there
are a lot of really good horror movies
that came out like in the 90s and early
2000s but in general I'm not a big fan
of particularly the early 2000s horror
movies like I said a lot of good ones
did come out around that time period too
so I'm not saying they all sucked but a
lot of the mainstream horror movies that
came out in the late 90s and early 2000s
not really a fan of not really a fan of
and as you know and I watch them like
nowadays and I'm just like oh my God
that is just that's painful painful to
watch
okay that was that was them right there
that was that
this one here does my ex-wife's little
shorter one was Melissa and me and me
and Melissa would sit around talk about
we would talk about paranormal [ __ ] over
her house and she in her house is
[ __ ] awesome
it was a little [ __ ] Southern house
that looked like a damn witch's Shack
Jenny would love it
and she sit there and [ __ ] make that
[ __ ] Indian spice chai I tea
and [ __ ] make uh
Indian curry tuna I eat her out of the
house at home I'd eat all that [ __ ]
and then um her sister and everything
lived across the way you know she lived
on one of those Southern
family compounds where all the houses
were just right you know what I mean you
didn't circle around each other and [ __ ]
you guys never seen those
but uh yeah I can we'd sit there and
talk about Art Bell and uh [ __ ] that
whole Blair Witch thing
and we thought it was based on something
that had really happened
and she and I didn't know anything about
it she would tell tell me like somehow
she knew more about it than I did or she
was making up more I don't [ __ ] know
but then we'd go online
and in those days you needed a web TV or
you needed a computer to go online you
couldn't go on with a phone we didn't
have [ __ ] phones
like you have today you had cell phones
but you couldn't get internet on a cell
phone you know
and I remember there was a like a like a
bunch of text and a whole website and
everything it was quite interesting for
the time well like I said it was super
ahead of itself yeah it was way ahead of
time
the first movie that marketed itself
like yeah
you know yeah almost like an ARG would
be now yeah ARG that's what we're
talking about because she
Melissa
she would bring up stuff about murder
cases that had happened
and the [ __ ] would sound outlandish as
[ __ ] and she would show me
on like either web TV or whatever
computer I think she was on a web TV at
that time of what it was
that she was talking about but looking
back on it they were aargs the ARG ARG
ARG alternate reality yeah well I think
she actually believed him
because they were new
well yeah that's I mean that's kind of
the whole point of them is that you're
supposed to make them look as realistic
as possible
you know what I mean so I think there
was something about some girl who went
missing in Mississippi but it was fake I
think once you got down to it
Adriana said are those redneck biker
bars like the near dark one where Bill
Paxton and the Gang massacred a lot of
people I was kind of thinking about that
too
they they kind of look like that I'll
show you what they look like I got
pictures of it
Sly says drinking Modelo Especial oh
yeah yeah deciding on summons for jury
duty this Monday no t-shirts no jeans no
sneakers
that sucks what are you gonna wear
does it say could just show up naked
mango said scream really killed Horror
in that time period that's that's the
thing and I'm not [ __ ] on Scream
because I actually really like that
movie but
okay
[Music]
um
but I don't I don't know like everything
that came in the wake of it was just
like not I don't know I just couldn't
get into it so I don't know I don't I
don't blame scream maybe [ __ ] would have
gone that way anyways
because I don't know
scream was like really clever
but all the ones that came after that
were like not
and then like the early 2000s I kind of
feel like it was almost all
yeah that's what that's what it looks
like on the inside during the day
I'm at the up at the bar taking a
picture of that
it just looks like a bunch of it yeah
you can't really see what it looks like
yeah
and the lights are actually kind of
bright in that one
um
this is what
hold on
[ __ ]
I guess that's what it looks like
from out front
she's talking about her motorcycle I
think I'll turn it back around when you
turn when you go back around in front
it'll show the club not the club but the
Oasis
when I pan back around
she's talking about all the
modifications she's going to do to her
little there it is see it behind the
bike
like that
it's got
um
cactuses and [ __ ] painted on it
and it's just on the side of the road
out in the country
okay
but yeah what up oh it's okay I'm
showing the bikes and then I show my
bike
that's my bike right there
that's a better shot of it
okay
okay
done
what I was gonna say was that
um I thought that
early 2000s in particular was kind of
like really bad for
remaking a lot of stuff from the 70s and
also doing English language versions of
Asian horror most of which were okay but
were inferior to The Originals although
I will defend the ring as being one that
I liked better than the Asian original
but most of them were oh yeah the
American version of The Grudge was okay
too but I still think the Asian one was
better
but I think the ring the American
version of the Ring was actually better
than the
than the Japanese one
so fight me
I don't think that's that controversial
an opinion the Japanese one is good too
I just I thought the American one was
much scarier
and let's see
I kind of now you're making me want to
watch Blair Witch 2 again because
maybe I don't know it's been a long time
since I've seen it but I remembered kind
of liking it
you know what I mean I might have seen
it in the theater
now that I'm thinking about it let me go
get some more you want some more drinks
or does he still drinking that I'm still
drinking that but you can give me
another one if you want because this is
almost one of the can
um
maybe another drink because these are
good but they're kind of like
they're kind of rich I might save the
other one for tomorrow because like I
said this does not it doesn't taste
alcoholic it tastes almost like a
dessert because it's like
because it's like a really sweet like
pumpkin spice latte
mango said the House of Wax remake was
Dreadful yeah see it's like it was all
that kind of stuff it just seemed like
it was all of these
I don't know it just seemed like
everything was like all of these kind of
like perfect 90210 Dawson's Creek
[ __ ] and it's like let's have a
movie where all of these annoying ass
perfect people in their 20s are being
picked off
by
a killer and it's just I don't know they
just didn't really have a lot of
personality to them and it's just I
don't know I didn't like a lot of the
[ __ ] that came out back then like I said
to be honest
as far as horror goes like I said 70s
were probably my favorite decade but
I've seen lately I've seen like but way
more like horror movies that I liked
from the past 10 20 years than I did
like in the whole of the probably 90s
and 2000s gonna say like after about
2008 2009 like then the [ __ ] started
getting good again
but
I don't know late 90s to early 2000s
there were some good movies it's
scattered through there but
a lot of them I just I just didn't
really like
um yeah grandma said even though the
2003 Texas Chainsaw was good it has a
lot of the symptoms of it yeah and I
yeah I didn't actually mind that
um I think I might have seen that in the
theater too and I was like oh that
wasn't bad
it's not as good as the original
obviously but you know it but it wasn't
terrible it wasn't as bad as I expected
and some of the [ __ ] um too was like
that uh that Dawn of the Dead remake
when did that come out 2004 was it 2004
uh that was actually that was pretty
damn good I mean I thought that was
really good even though like when I was
hearing about it coming out I was like
Jesus Christ you're really gonna remake
Dawn of the Dead but then I saw it and I
was like okay all right all right I'll
allow it that was really good especially
like that whole opening sequence was
pretty [ __ ] Dynamite
foreign
I have to admit I did enjoy Cherry Falls
I've been meaning to that because I kind
of feel like a lot of people have
recommended that to me as like one that
was sort of like forgotten and I don't
know so I just like saw it the other day
when I was scrolling through like some
of the stuff and I was like man I should
get around to watching that because I
kind of feel like I just I saw a few
like in the late 90s and you know like I
Know What You Did Last Summer and all
that kind of stuff and I was just like
yeah I'm kind of over this whole
whatever it is they're doing so I didn't
see a lot of them
I think like recently maybe it was last
February
I think we reviewed that movie Valentine
which came out I think in the 90s or
early 2000s that was okay but it had
that kind of
Sheen to it that I'm not like a big fan
of that early 2000s
thing you know mango said 70s and early
80s was some of the best times for
Horror oh yeah I agree
I agree what's up Pokey
I mean I'm not like averse to the idea
of remakes in general
I just wish that if you're gonna remake
A Movie remake something that wasn't
that great to start with you know what I
mean yeah they're trying to make it a
cash crap though it'll never happen well
I know that but I'm just saying but yeah
but there was like a lot of movies that
came out in the 70s that were like okay
or were like a really good concept but
you know we're let down by you know we
didn't have the budget to do what we
wanted or you know something take
something like that and improve upon it
don't take something and like I said we
were talking about this the other day
with Rob Zombie I was just like don't
take something like Halloween which is
like a classic and iconic and perfect
the way it is and try to remake it it's
like you're not you're just gonna
like why why bother there's a million
zillion movies that came out in the 70s
and 80s that were kind of shitty but
were like good ideas or had their
moments get one of those and remake that
you know what I mean it could even be
one that was kind of like well known
but just wasn't all that great
I mean look at like Judd you could
remake that
like it's fun it wouldn't be the same
like as the 80s one and I know a lot of
people would like but but that's kind of
what I'm talking about like that was a
good movie for the 80s but it's like
that could be done again that could that
concept could be done again and you
could like you know what I mean you
could redo Trilogy of Terror
yeah but you don't have Karen Black
though you have to get somebody else
who's like that
because I kind of feel like the whole
cool thing about Trilogy of Terror is
that Karen Black is in all three parts
of it I mean that and the little doll
and everything so I'm saying that little
what's called a zindy doll what's it
called a zindy doll what was that thing
called is that the Zuni I thought it was
really Zuni with an N you could do you
could do that a lot better today
although I have to say for the time and
and the fact that it was made for TV
yeah it was still good they did an
amazingly good job with that little and
I know it was like mostly just like a
puppet and like other kind of stuff like
that but I was like man the way they
shot that was fantastic I mean that was
[ __ ]
Dan Curtis directed that man he always
said he did burnt offerings in Christ it
was one of my favorite movies of the 70s
I was just talking about that today
because I'm doing I'm putting up a video
on scare salon tomorrow which is if you
guys have been following my series I've
been doing
um my top five favorite horror movies
from every year since I was born so the
one that I'm putting up tomorrow is
1976. so
1976 it was like really hard because
I looked at the list of all the horror
movies that came out in 1976 and I was
it was hard to get it down to five some
years it's not as hard because like some
years it's just kind of like well
there's a lot of movies that I didn't
really love or I didn't see them you
know what I mean or there was like a lot
of like really shitty cheap ones but
then there's years like 1973 or 1976
were like a [ __ ] ton of really good ones
I mean 1976 you had
carry you have the tenant you had like
like all of these really good movies and
it was like really really hard to pick
Obama says I think 80s horror slasher
sequels are important We're Never
Getting that anything like that again
mango says the first half of zombies
Halloween remake is great it really
falls apart in the second half and it
really falls apart yeah I think that's
the problem I kind of feel like I saw in
the theater
and I remember
being averse to the idea
just from in general but I said well I'm
gonna go see it and then at first yeah
it was it was kind of like okay this
this is all right it's not that bad but
then like the more that he explained it
like I said we've got into this before
like why the [ __ ] do you want to
demystify
Michael Myers he was just an abused kid
who grew up with this like don't [ __ ]
do that it's not scary anymore
yeah
yeah that the holy parachute said
exactly that the thing with Halloween
since the killer was written to be a
quasi Supernatural entity the less you
knew or saw of him out of his murderous
form made it ineffective there's a lot
of [ __ ] like zombie made him too human
that's what I mean it's like the reason
he was scary was because you didn't know
like really anything about him or like
where he was just kind of like every now
and then he'd pop out from behind the
bushes and it's just kind of and it's
scary you didn't know what his deal was
you know what his motives were he that's
scarier to me that's what went wrong
with Terminator and Predator talking too
much about [ __ ] Skynet and the
Terminators and too much about predators
letting you know too much you're not
supposed to know them very much you just
what they show you they're never really
supposed to reveal you know what I mean
demystify it then its power is gone
that that that's what I mean it pulls
over you it's such
it's really a delicate balance if you go
too far in the other direction where you
like don't show anything then you're
gonna get a bunch of people like that or
be like well it wasn't even show
anything like how the [ __ ] am I supposed
to which I don't agree with that
necessarily but I kind of feel like
if you leave things ambiguous or you
leave things to a point where you're not
really showing the monster at all then
you're gonna piss a lot of people off on
the other hand if you show the monster
too much or explain too much about her
or something like that then it just
becomes not scary you have to get that
exactly right thing where you kind of
just show enough of the monster to like
trigger people's imaginations
and that's it
yeah I mean a good example
of a franchise
that showed you a little bit more but
then the mystery deepened would be the
thing
the thing one you knew very little
about the thing and then when thing 2011
came out which is a prequel
shows how the Norwegians found the
saucer
they even show you inside the saucer
but the mystery [ __ ] increased
because that thing was so different you
just couldn't understand it I mean
they found I guess the control room
where the computers were and all it was
is just a bunch of dab
cubes and cubes stacking on top of one
each other and Vanishing and reappearing
like I don't know if the cubes are
really there if it was a dam hologram
but they're looking at it like what the
[ __ ] is that and it's just something
that only an alien would understand
and that was beautiful that was
beautiful
don't [ __ ] demystify it increase the
mystery
because that's going to make people talk
about it yeah and come up with theories
right especially nowadays something as
bizarre an alien as bizarre as the thing
whatever
controls it had control in that ship you
wouldn't be able to make headers and
Tails out of them and that's that's what
they're showing that's what they showed
a bunch of Gray
cubes of different [ __ ] Hues just
appearing and disappearing and stacking
and unstacking and flowing over and just
like [ __ ] is that it's that's what the
alien that's alien graphics
[Laughter]
that's the ship that's the ship's main
computer
and uh
I thought that was beautiful great
fantastic that's how you do it the
mystery deepens it's so alien you can't
even [ __ ] understand the control
surfaces
you know well like I said that's
probably what it would be like in real
life yeah so right you think you're
gonna go into an alien ship there's
gonna be chairs
you know and buttons to push aliens
don't have butts yeah
it's gonna be something you can't
comprehend
or something you can't see maybe because
they may not be using eyes
Zach says uh the movie with Anna De
armas as Marilyn Monroe is out now and
it seems to be really surreal and kind
of horror-like yeah I've been hearing
some really interesting things about
that and I kind of want to see it
because I love annadarmus so I kind of
feel like
I'll get around to watching it Cuomo
said the editing is unreal so good it's
so surreal in a trip see now now you
guys are making me want to watch it
God damn Tom
mango says uh that's
that's what made the original Friday the
13th so great you never found out who
who the killer was to the last five
minutes
yeah I'm more of a fan of like
ambiguity like not
like I said this is what I meant when I
said you know that's uh it's a delicate
balance you can't just come in there and
be like weird [ __ ] and then buy you know
what I mean like that doesn't mean
anything or that you know doesn't
suggest anything you do kind of have to
have an idea behind it a concept behind
it but within those parameters I think
it's better to leave as much stuff
unexplained as possible just give people
enough information so they can come to
their own conclusions and you know come
up with their own theories and I think
that's like way way better
that's way better
holy Parish of Doom says the original
Friday the 13th is solid uh that one
black Christmas and Halloween are really
the only slasher flicks I dig yeah all
of those are good and honestly
I don't know I gotta tell you I think
part two is better than part one what
Friday 13. I I slightly like Friday the
13th too better than part one as well I
like part one but I think part two I
like it and I didn't think three three
in 3D was all that bad either yeah it
had some cheesy scenes in it I still
don't like three I still don't like
three not that I I kind of liked it the
second one is my favorite one yeah I
think so
because that's one with Jason
and then you find the mom's head yeah
now it's [ __ ] awesome with the
sweater yeah it was good yeah and then
she's all like pretended to be there I'm
like ew that was [ __ ] great I love
that one was great too but I think I
think two is a little bit better now I
did like Betsy Palmer as the killer like
when you found out this nice old lady in
the fisherman sweater the Killer
uh Victor says hey I made it hey what's
going on sorry Tom's dying over there
yeah
um
uh let's see yeah Guam said it's
lynching as [ __ ] see now I really want
to see it the Marilyn Monroe movie that
sounds awesome
um let's see
Jeff here it says I think people want to
see the monster and not use their own
imagination because they know their
imagination is far more horrifying
seeing the fake CGI monster will get
them out of the headspace ooh that's
kind of an interesting take on it I
never really thought about it like that
maybe people that kind of like horror
movies but not but aren't like nerds
about it like I am maybe that is why
maybe that's kind of why
movies you know kind of like Conjuring
Universe movies and stuff like that tend
to do better even though to me they seem
like all a bunch of like jump scares and
stuff which is not really all that scary
to me maybe that's why maybe people can
like there they see the movie and they
can get a handle on the scary thing
well my experience was is that
there are a lot of fans certain
franchises that are so Fanboy about it
they get involved in extended Universe
stuff
and then when a new movie comes out and
it doesn't conform to something in the
in the extended uniform verse they
reject the movie yeah it might be that
too and uh one that comes to mind would
be Prometheus one and two
because people had their own these super
fans had their own preconceived notions
about
the engineering the aliens and all that
never Xenomorphs and they didn't like
how that story went
and I agree in Prometheus one they cut
too much of it out but if you see if you
get the Blu-ray version and watch the
extended edition it's a lot better
they should have never cut that movie up
like they did they were just dumb to cut
some of those scenes out of there
they were trying to add to the mystery
but really it kind of added to the
frustration I guess for a lot of people
what this was what what this movie was
about
um yeah that that might have been again
what I was talking about where it's good
to like cut out a lot of stuff but that
one I think the theatrical cut they cut
out too much so that mostly it it just
left people like confused and pissed off
rather than intrigued and like wanting
to learn more like I said that's what I
mean when I said it's like a delicate
balance of like what you should leave
out because the whole movie's about
trying to find these damn Engineers who
supposedly made mankind they finally get
one of one of them the last one to get
him out of [ __ ] hypersleep
and in the theatrical cut he just comes
up and just kills everybody
like what the [ __ ] with what the [ __ ]
did that mean but they cut out the
dialogue and the you see it in the
Extended Cut
and uh then there's some deleted scenes
on the Blu-ray and then some some
really good bonus material that talks
about Tyrell from [ __ ] Blade Runner
and everything
basically what happens in the movie
which is the [ __ ] whole meaning of
the movie they cut it away it didn't
make any [ __ ] sense the [ __ ]
the engineer comes out of [ __ ] hyper
sleep and he's like what are you doing
here why are you guys here
and [ __ ] the Android
says this man owns a powerful company
who's brought us here and he believes
you can give him eternal life
and [ __ ] the the engineer says what
gives him the right to ask for something
like eternal life
and [ __ ] he translated it and [ __ ]
um
what was his name Waylon gets up there
and he goes look me and you are creators
we're creating things see this Android
man I built him out of my company built
him out of nothing and uh [ __ ] we're
creating life basically like you and he
goes and just on the back of that me
being a Creator we deserve immortality
like you and that [ __ ]
alien looked at he looked at that
[ __ ] Android and tore its head off
and [ __ ] beat the old dude to death
with it
and then ran off and then [ __ ]
activated the ship to go to Earth to
destroy Earth
but they stopped him
and so you're like
and that was beautiful man that's the
way the movie should have been but for
some reason they cut that out it was
just dumb dumb
and then the sequel to it because people
didn't like the first one they tweaked
the sequel and went away from the whole
how how humans were created and why
they went away from that story and
that's that was a great story that they
were telling we were created the same
way and the same reason for why Tyrell
made the replicants that's why you know
to serve our masters
a terraforming [ __ ] basically that's
part of the reason another reason is try
to to help the [ __ ] Engineers reach
re-achieve immortality or not
immortality but to reach achieve the
ability to procreate because they
couldn't have children
there was a great story but
they scrapped the script
dumb
because that [ __ ] would have [ __ ]
flown real well I I guess Ridley Scott
didn't have what it took to fight the
studios but his original script is
[ __ ] great it's leaked onto the
internet and when you read it you're
like oh okay you know and it just would
have been a movie on par with 2001 a
[ __ ] Space Odyssey better probably
okay she's back
what were you talking about yeah I was
talking bad about you yeah I figured
yeah
uh somebody said uh I think that was
mango yeah uh said great slasher for
everyone I've forgotten When My Bloody
Valentine yeah I agree that's a good one
uh we actually reviewed that um either
this past Valentine's Day or the one
before that movie scared the crap out of
me when I was a kid I don't know why
because it's not that scary but it's
good see see the um the unrated one
though it's like wake Warrior uh
somebody's asking about Grave Encounters
yeah that's a really good one that's
kind of found footage too isn't it even
and I don't usually like found footage
all that much but that one that's a good
one actually
and let's see somebody says that those
movies also demystified alien that came
before no not really there's a bunch of
[ __ ]
that was still never unanswered
about the Xenomorph
yeah in the second one
the Android makes a xenomorph but it's
not quite the same Xenomorph
it's something else I mean it kind of
does the same thing but he stole that
technology so it doesn't really answer
what what that was it was some kind of a
something they made up I don't think
maybe they actually have a
have a reason for it or an explanation
for it
because when alien one came out it was
just called the [ __ ] biomechanoid a
living machine man
you know so in other words it's kind of
like a replica
but as a replicant made by aliens
it's some kind of a servant
and it and it reproduces with you
Adriana said Jenny have you seen uh
pupiavati's uh household house with the
Laughing Windows uh quite mccably is a
bad taste in your mouth and the end is
quite depressing yeah I actually love
that movie
um I've seen it a couple of times I
should do a video about it I feel like I
don't think I've I wrote like a review
for it on my uh website but I don't
think I ever did a video about it and I
probably should because I really
actually really do like that movie and
matter of fact the video that I'm
putting up tomorrow that actually was
one of the honorable mentions because it
came out in 1976. Zach says what bugs me
is that the horror movies that are crap
and non-scary only seem to make money
where the ones that are actually good
and scary always seem to bomb I kind of
feel like that's
I don't know that's that's usually true
like kind of across the board because I
feel like the best horror movies
you know even the ones back in the 70s
and 80s a lot of them didn't really get
appreciated at the time it was only kind
of like later on
not always some were like appreciated as
soon as they came out like everybody
recognized it but you know the big
example of that being like the thing
which
is amazing and you know one of the best
horror movies ever and yet it didn't
really do all that well when it came out
like people didn't really respond to
them for whatever reason it just took a
while to like find its audience and I
kind of feel like that happens with a
particular kind of horror movie it's
really really easy to make money with
like I said kind of like you know Blum
House's formula or like The Conjuring
Universe movies and I'm not [ __ ] on
those because I like some of those as
well and like they do what they set out
to do usually but a lot of those I don't
know if people will still be talking
about them in 40 or 50 years time you
know what I mean like the way that some
people talk about classic horror movies
from like the 60s nowadays I don't know
if people will be talking about a Blum
House movie 40 50 years from now you
know they're good when you see them but
they're just kind of like yeah
forgettable you know what I mean that's
all Oscar's saying that that's you say
in the scene with the with the engineer
he thought it was ridiculous but I don't
know which scene he's talking about yeah
I don't know if he's talking about the
one that got or the one that was kept
because the one that was cut I thought
it was good
the one that was in the [ __ ] the one
that was kept and putting the movie out
this thought was [ __ ]
big disappointment I mean they spent all
that time to [ __ ] get that dude out
of [ __ ] sleep and he wakes up and
just kills everybody
you know it just
kind of dumb
but what they said goes along the lines
of the [ __ ] Blade Runner and Ridley
Scott stuff is that rich oligarchs want
to replace us with
at basically either Androids or
biologically
engineered products that are human-like
because they're easier to control
and that goes along with [ __ ] with
the second part of Blade Runner that's
good too so it all kinds of goes into
that same theme so I like that theme
it's just that it didn't quite get it
that one right and then the second one
Prometheus two I think they called it
alien something or other
it had good parts in it you could see
where they were trying to go with that
but they changed it
did you please the crowd and it didn't
work it didn't work
they should have stuck stepped to their
guns and stayed on the original path
and maybe and saved the first movie they
could have saved the first movie that
way but they didn't
Really Scott he couldn't fight the
studios I guess or he was dropped
pictures that I watched Martyrs for the
first time last weekend that's a pretty
[ __ ] up movie um if you haven't seen
it uh then fell sleeping on a nightmare
so I liked it I guess it definitely
wasn't about what I thought it was going
to be about yeah that's um
that one's a rough one it's a rough one
to Center
um I I liked it I guess too but I don't
know if I'd ever want to sit through it
again I probably will at some point Mega
said speak no evil is a recent horror
film that has really stuck with me uh
once seen never forgotten is that the
one that's on is it on shutter because I
was like looking at the new stuff on
shutter and that did kind of look
interesting if that's the same one that
you're talking about so I might put that
down
um and watch that this month at some
point like for my other series because
I'm always looking for like if you guys
that have shutter or even if you have
any of the other like Hulu or anything
like that if you see like a kick-ass
horror movie on there that you think I
would like like tell me because I don't
always like I try to keep track and keep
up with new [ __ ] but I can't and I
usually like um agree with like y'all's
taste so I need a way to like winnow
through the stuff because there's just
so many coming out that I can't keep up
yeah said yeah it's on shutter it's
Danish or something okay yeah okay well
I'll watch that then then Oscar says
yeah the the scene that they kept was
[ __ ] up it was yeah it was and then
the scene that they threw away they gave
you more information of explanation that
was pretty good scene when I bought the
Blu-ray and then saw the scene and the
movie made sense more so that would have
brought the movie up to 75.80 right
there you could have had a good sequel
just going along that path but they just
I guess it was a bad time for movies in
this [ __ ] Studios wanted more than
what was possible I guess but I thought
the movie looked great it had a lot of
good ideas
the black mutagenic goo I was interested
man you know just that it was not edited
in a way that was
ah I don't want to say coherent it was
kind of coherent just that you didn't
know what anything was
and and then David the robot takes you a
while you got to watch it a bunch of
times to realize it's actually him and
Vickers that are in charge of everything
they're they're doing the investigation
the humans are just there to be test
subjects they're not doing anything that
was the idea they chose the worst people
possible to go on the mission so they
could kill them use them as test
subjects every one of those people every
one of those humans was bad they were
bad at their job every one of them on
purpose they didn't want them asking any
questions they just wanted to use them
use that damn black goo on them
or use them as test subjects or
something
but they were going to kill them because
they were out in neutral waters you know
you could do whatever you wanted on that
planet to them you weren't inside
anybody's jurisdiction
so but they didn't make any of that [ __ ]
clear to the audience you have to I
watched that movie a lot a long time
to try to attest to it I saw that [ __ ]
[ __ ] 30 times trying to figure that
[ __ ] out because I knew there was a
message there but there's not enough
information they don't give you enough
holy Parish of Doom said we're going to
see terrifier 2 this next week ooh
that's a good one well into the prior
one terrifier one was really good yeah I
really liked that a lot uh with art the
clown yeah and uh there was actually a
movie before like an anthology film that
had where art the clown the the
character came from what the [ __ ] was
the name of that thing it was on 2B I
watched it last Halloween I think or the
Halloween before
um but yeah I really really liked
terrifier that was and I'm not usually
into the whole evil clown thing but that
was a really good one and the gore was
off the chain I was I was really into it
it was super fun uh said the same
theater is also running full cheese
zombie and Rosemary's Baby in October
going to both that's the thing now that
October is here that means that all the
movie theaters and all this all the
channels and everything like that are
doing their 30 days of Halloween I was
thinking about doing because remember
you guys remember last year
on my over on my flickers of fear thing
I did eek week so I did kind of like
Halloween themed movies like every day I
don't know if I'm gonna have time to do
that this year because
you know I started two new channels also
but I have been I'm kind of like
I don't know if you guys know but I try
to keep everything like a month ahead
you well usually like a two three four
weeks ahead so usually like at the end
of one month like a week before the end
of one month I'll put up a calendar
I have this big calendar and I'll write
down like all the book reviews and all
the movies that I'm planning sometimes
I'll move them around like if something
gets taken off or something new comes
out that I want to see your blah blah
blah but I'll do that
so I scheduled
I'm doing like a bunch of Halloween
books like I did find like three or four
Halloween themed novels that I wanted to
read so I'm gonna do kind of Halloween
book themes like toward the end of the
month and I'm probably I'm honestly
though I'm running out of good Halloween
themed movies like I seem it feels like
we've talked about like all the good
like last year I did you know I did
Hocus Pocus and I did the witches and I
did like all the you know all the lady
in white like I did all the good
Halloween themed movies so now I kind of
feel like it's just kind of like shitty
ones so I'm like I'm gonna try and find
some to do like as Halloween gets closer
but I don't know we'll see if we if I
get to the month end of the month and
like I have more time then maybe I'll
add more like special because I don't
know it always makes me mad because I
always want to do more stuff for
Halloween because I [ __ ] love
Halloween that's my favorite but then
like it always kind of like sneaks up on
me and then by the time it gets here I'm
like well [ __ ] I wanted to do this that
and the other thing and I don't have
time to do it but I definitely will do
some more I'm definitely doing some
Halloween books I already checked them
out like on my Kindle unlimited and
everything so I'm definitely gonna do
that and I have some ideas for some
Halloween themed movies but like I said
I'm running out of good ones and I don't
necessarily just want to watch a bunch
of like shitty
you know uh [ __ ] 2B original dollar
fifty movies because like dollar fifty
to make I mean because just because
they're Halloween themed I definitely
want some good ones but I feel like
we've done all the good ones like we did
trick or treat we did all of those so I
don't know we'll see how it goes we'll
see how it goes uh holy parachute said
by the way I checked out Jenny's review
of bug interesting flick I think a lot
of people misinterpret the story as just
a crazy paranoid guy who infects the
woman with his bugginess yeah the thing
about it I'm glad that a couple people
like commented on that is like oh my God
I love this movie and I'm glad you're
talking about it because I feel like
nobody does and I was like that's what I
thought too I saw it in the theater and
I [ __ ] loved it
and then I was like oh I wanted to watch
it again because [ __ ] Michael Shannon
man he's great and Ashley Judd is in it
and it's directed by William friedkin
you know the same guy that did The
Exorcist and I was just kind of like
nobody [ __ ] talks about it anymore
and it is so good it's so good it's like
it was based on a play and like as you
can tell because it just takes place
almost entirely like in one hotel room
but the acting in it is just is
phenomenal it's so so good and I just it
came out in 2006 and I just feel like
it's sad that like a lot of people don't
talk about it anymore
um so when I saw that it was on Hulu or
Amazon Prime or whatever I said oh [ __ ]
man I'm gonna talk about that because I
love that movie it's almost 8 30 are you
getting hungry uh a little bit yeah
we've been on for two and a half hours
so yeah
um Ben says All Hallows Eve did we do
that one I don't know I have to look
because
we've done like so many Halloween movies
oh all Hollywood's Eve was the one that
was uh the art the clown one that's
right
we reviewed it but I have seen it you
should do all those Halloween scary
house movies like the houses that
October built I think we
I think I might have done that one
I'm pretty sure we did houses October
built I have to look go back and look I
know I've seen it I just don't know if
we reviewed it or not
um holy Parish of Doom said yeah yeah
Michael Shannon's character perspective
is spot on minus is yeah that's what I'm
saying it's just kind of like
the cool thing about that movie I don't
want to like spoil too much about it in
case like people haven't seen it
but you could interpret it as Michael
Shannon is just
a schizophrenic and has you know
infected this woman with his crazy
conspiracy theories or
uh maybe he's right and all that stuff
is going on or
Maybe
he's just like maybe everything in the
movie is just from his pers you know
perspective so it's not how that's
happening you know what I mean like it's
almost kind of like you don't know if
you're what you're seeing is reality if
you're just seeing seeing things
filtered through his mental illness it
could go either way and I like that
about it that's what I thought was cool
uh Oscar said Jenny yeah everybody's
telling me my best friend's exorcism is
on Prime yeah um I'm gonna watch that
I'll probably put up a review of it on
uh Thursday because I just saw that it
was up and I really want to see it
connovason says the new season of Cobra
Kai is up yeah I heard that was
fantastic I heard that was going on
[ __ ] loves it maybe we should start
watching yeah
he says it's great
because I didn't ask one yeah
I can't but it seemed like the last one
just went up not too long ago am I crazy
if I remember if he if I understand what
he told me there's a brand new one well
remember I told you the other day
because I just saw something in the news
and I was like oh the new Cobra Kai's
season is out already and I was like it
seemed like the old one just came he
says it's the best one it doesn't pull
any punches
all right yeah
uh Victor said did y'all ever watch take
shelter yeah we did we did a um I think
we did a matinee on it a while back
yeah we did it was a while ago yeah
Michael Shannon's great Michael
Shannon's great well honestly like I I
wanted you to see bug as well I don't
know I don't know if you'd like it or
not like I said I already reviewed it so
we're not gonna do like a matinee I put
it in the poll a few times but it never
did win and then I was like [ __ ] it I'm
just gonna do it myself because I
because I'd seen it and I really liked
it so I'm gonna do it again I don't know
if you'd like it or not because
it's
it's not a horror movie necessarily it's
like psychological and like I said it's
based on a play so a lot of it is just
kind of like two people in a room like
talking but I don't know like you might
dig it though are you hungry yeah I'm
gonna make some tacos uh sure okay sure
I gotta go in a bit all right
um
let's see Adriana said yeah they're
talking about uh Barbara Steele [ __ ]
like that okay so Tom seems like he
wants to yeah I've been gone for two and
a half hours I gotta you know I gotta
start cooking I think he's gonna go make
some tacos I'm gonna go make some tacos
for everybody all right my leg is
hurting because I've been
[ __ ] sore man mega said if I recall
Wright friedkin's next film Killer Joe
was written by the same writer who wrote
bug yeah it was uh it's the same same
guy um Tracy let's yeah is the name of
the guy that wrote uh both the plays so
yeah so I guess we're gonna wrap it up
now I think that
um We're not gonna be back until Monday
because my sister is coming down
tomorrow I think if all the travel works
out because of all the hurricane
[ __ ] and me and her are gonna go to
the Disney Halloween thing like on
Sunday so I'm not gonna be here on
Sunday to do the matinee show but we
will be back on Monday to do a haunting
so that's the next time we'll go back to
I'm just kind of hoping that she can get
down here I haven't heard anything yet
so
because I know some of the airports are
closed still and [ __ ] like that but we
will be back on Monday to talk about a
haunting I don't know what
uh episode yet I'll let everybody know
so they can watch it ahead of time as I
usually do but thank you everybody for
dropping by this evening thanks for
super chats thanks for just being here
and hanging out with us because we
always enjoy this on Friday night and we
will see you guys again on Monday good
night